WE HAVE TO MEMBERS COME UP TO
THE DIE AS WE HOW THE FLOOR
QUORUM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LIKE TO OF A HOLIDAYS ARE.
OUR COMMITTEE HE.
TO ORDER. AND.
.
LIKE TO PERSIST ABOLITION A
QUORUM IN THOUGH.
A DOWN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
KANSEN.
KANSEN CHU AIR KANSEN CHU HERE
WALDRON.
ACOSTA HERE THE CONSTANT. DAVID
CHIU.
FRIEDMAN TREATMENT HERE. MEDINA.
YOUR MEDINA HERE MS ARYAN.
WE HAVE A QUIRK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HELP FOR
ITEMS TODAY.
AND THOUGH FIRST ONE ASSAULT
DOWN.
MEMBER CAO CALDERON HERE WHOM
WOULD YOU PLEASE COME UP.
AND PRESENT A AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY FOUR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YES MISTER BLOOM.
THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR YOUR TIME
THIS MORNING AB STE.
PRODUCTION TAX CREDIT FEW
INDUSTRIES ARE MORE INDELIBLY
TIED TO A LOCATION IN THE IN A
TENER INTO ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY IS THE CALIFORNIA.
THIS INDUSTRY CREATES HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF GOOD PAYING JOBS
MIDDLE CLASS JOBS AND BILLIONS
AND ECONOMIC ACTIVITY THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA EACH YEAR AND AS. AND
HOPEFULS STILL FLOCK TO THE AREA
WITH DREAMS OF BEING DISCOVERED.
UNFORTUNATELY SINCE THE LATE
NINETEEN NINETIES OTHER STATES
AND AND COUNTRIES HAVE LORD
PRODUCTION OUT OF CALIFORNIA
WITH GENEROUS TAX BREAKS IN
THOSE YEARS OF RUNAWAY
PRODUCTION CALIFORNIA SUFFERED.
MASSIVE LOSSES OF JOBS REVENUE
INVESTMENT AND THE EROSION OF
THE FILM INDUSTRY THE TOLL ON
WORKERS AND FAMILIES WITH THE
MEN SAYS FILM CREW MEMBER CREW
MEMBERS. TRAVEL TO OTHER STATES
FOLLOWING WORK LEAVING BEHIND
THEIR FAMILIES AND FACED
UNEMPLOYMENT HERE AT HOME. AN
EFFORT TO COMBAT PRODUCTION
FLIGHT LEGISLATURE PASSED THE
CALIFORNIA FILM AND TELEVISION
TAX CREDIT PROGRAM IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE THE PROGRAM HAS
BEEN IMPROVED UPON OVER THE
YEARS. INCLUDING REPLACING THE
OLD LOTTERY SYSTEM WITH THE JOBS
RATIO RANKING SYSTEM WHEREBY
APPLICATIONS ARE RANKED BASED
UPON THE NUMBER OF JOBS CREATED.
AND OTHER ECONOMIC FACTORS AS
WELL AS PROVIDING SPECIAL
INCENTIVES TO LARA TELEVISION
PROGRAMS BACK TO THE STATE. MOVE
THE BILL.
THE PRODUCTION TAX CREDIT
INCENTIVES I'M READING AT ALL OF
THE CREATION OF THE GOOD MIDDLE
CLASS BELOW THE LINE JOBS FOR
WORKERS. WHO DO TECHNICAL WORK
CREATING PROPS?
BUILDING SETS APPLYING MAKE UP
FINDING LOCATIONS AND ALL THE
WORK BEHIND THE SCENES THAT
MAKES PRODUCTION POSSIBLE THE
BENEFITS EXTEND BEYOND THE
THOUSANDS EMPLOYED THE FILM AND
TELEVISION PRODUCTION TO THE
ANCILLARY BUSINESSES THAT SERVE
THE PRODUCTION SITES IN TEAMS.
SUCH AS THE CATERERS HOTELS SET
CONSTRUCTION COMPANIES
RESTAURANTS ETCETERA FURTHER THE
STATE AS A WHOLE BENEFITS AS THE
TAX. REVENUE GENERATED FROM
FILMING HERE HERE HELPS
TO PAY FOR TEACHERS POLICE
OFFICERS AND AN INFRASTRUCTURE
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THE TAX CREDIT PROGRAM HAS A
PROVEN TRACK RECORD OF CREATING
A RETAINING JOBS IN THE FILM
INDUSTRY IN FACT THE FILM
COMMISSION RECENTLY COMPLETED.
ALL ALLOCATIONS FOR THE CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR ACCORDING TO THE
PROGRAM THEIR THE PRELIMINARY
DATA FOR THE FIRST THREE YEARS
OF THE PROGRAM TO POINT OUT. WE
HAVE ALLOCATED EIGHT HUNDRED
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS IN TAX
CREDITS TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
APPROVED PROJECTS TOGETHER THESE
PROJECTS CAN ARE CONTRIBUTING
FIVE POINT NINE BILLION. OF
DIRECT IN STATE SPENDING
INCLUDING TWO POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS IN WAGES TO THE
TECHNICAL CREW AND THIS EXCLUDES
ANY WAGES PAID FOR WRITERS
DIRECTORS PRODUCERS ARE ACTORS
AS THOSE WAGES ARE NOT. ELIGIBLE
FOR TAX CREDITS AS FOR JOBS
WHICH IS WHAT THIS TAX CREDIT
HAS ALWAYS BEEN ABOUT WE'VE SEEN
A TWELVE PERCENT INCREASE IN
HOURS WORKED. TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND CAST MEMBERS HIRED
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND CREW MEMBERS
HIRED IN ANOTHER FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND BACKGROUND
HIRES WHICH ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
HIRED ON A DAILY BASIS. WE'VE
ALSO HAD THIRTEEN TV SERIES
WOULD RELOCATE TO CALIFORNIA
FROM OUT OF STATE. THREE SERIES
MOVED FROM NEW YORK FOR FROM
VANCOUVER THE REST CAME FROM
NORTH CAROLINA MARYLAND TEXAS
LOUISIANA AND FLORIDA THE
CURRENT PROGRAM SUNSET IN TWO
YEARS ON JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY. DUE TO THE COMPLEXITY OF
MOTION PICTURE AND TELEVISION
PRODUCTION DECISIONS REGARDING
SHOOT LOCATIONS ARE MADE OFTEN A
YEAR OR MORE IN ADVANCE.
MOTION PICTURE AND TELEVISION
PRODUCTIONS IN NEED THE
CERTAINTY OF THAT CALIFORNIA
FILM AND TELEVISION TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM IN ORDER TO CONSIDER
CALIFORNIA. AS A LOCATION AND
THE PRODUCTION PLANNING WHICH IS
WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY HEARING
THIS BILL AND WORKING ON IT THIS
YEAR. AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOUR
WILL CONTINUE THE EXISTING
PROGRAM WITH SOME IMPROVEMENTS
AS WELL WE WILL FURTHER
INCENTIVIZE THE USE OF
CALIFORNIA MUSICIANS FOR FILM
AND TELEVISION SCORING AS WELL
AS PROVIDE ADDITIONAL CREDIT TO
PRODUCTIONS. THAT FILM OUTSIDE
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY TO ENSURE
THAT THE ENTIRE STATE IS A
BENEFICIARY. FINALLY THIS BILL
WHICH WILL CREATE A CAREER
PATHWAYS TRAINING PROGRAM
FOCUSED ON UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES IN OUR STATE. THE
CAREER PATHWAYS TRAINING
PROGRAM.
WILL CREATE THE NEXT GENERATION
OF WELL PAID HIGHLY SKILLED
WORKERS IN OUR LOCAL ECONOMIES
AND MAKE SURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
FILMMAKING WORKFORCE REMAINS AT
THE FOREFRONT OF THE INDUSTRY.
WHILE BEING MORE REPRESENTATIVE
OF OUR STATES DIVERSE POPULATION
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOUR WILL
CONTINUE TO RESTORE CALIFORNIA'S
COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE FOR FILM
AND TELEVISION AND IN TELEVISION
PRODUCTION. AND TO BRING JOBS
BACK TO CALIFORNIA THUS ENSURING
THAT THIS VIBRANT FOUNDATIONAL
INDUSTRY REMAINS PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S LEGACY. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME MEMBERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AFTER MY GREAT COLLEAGUE JOINT
AUTHORS TO ME MEMBER BLOOM AND
MAKES HIS REMARKS ARE WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
MARK WALTER THE DIRECTOR OF
STUDIO DEVELOPMENT. FOR SIMILES
AND GENERAL MANAGER FOR FOR FILL
MARE ISLAND LOCATED NEARBY IN
NEARBY VALLEJO AS WELL AS ALISON
TAYLOR A LOCATION MANAGER AND
MEMBER OF TEAMSTERS LOCAL THREE
NINETY NINE. AND I ALSO WANT TO
THANK AMY BLEMISH THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA FILM
COMMISSION FOR BEING HERE TODAY
TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU FOR CHAIR.
AS.
MR BLOWN.
FORMER MEMBER MISTER BLOW A HOLE
MORE MEMBERS. THANK THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND. MEMBERS OF
THIS VERY IMPORTANT COMMITTEE OF
I WANT TO BEGIN BY THANKING GOD
OF MISTER CALDERON FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND AS
WELL THE BROAD COALITION OF
ADVOCATES HAVE WORKED HARD. TO
UP UP PULL THIS TOGETHER I WAS A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR OF VERSION
TWO POINT OUT IT HAS BEEN AN
UNQUALIFIED SUCCESS AND
CALIFORNIA'S. FILM INDUSTRIES
YOU ALL THOSE ONE OF THE
HALLMARKS OF OUR GREAT STATE IT
EMPLOYS HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE IN ITS CREATED INCREDIBLE
CULTURAL AND ARTISTIC
TOUCHSTONES.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW THE INDUSTRY
HAS FOR YEARS BEEN MOVING TO
OTHER PARTS OF THE COUNTRY DUE
PRIMARILY TO INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED IN.
OF OTHER STATES AND.
INTERNATIONALLY AS WELL.
OUR TWENTY FOURTEEN REVISION OF
THE FILM TAX CREDIT AS I SAID
IT'S BEEN AN UNQUALIFIED SUCCESS
IN HELPING REVERSE THAT TREND
AND BREATHING LIFE INTO AN
INDUSTRY THAT WAS. BORN IN
RICHARD HERE AND IT HAS BEEN A
MAINSTAY OF OUR ECONOMY FOR MANY
MANY DECADES NOW. OVER THE FIRST
TWO YEARS SINCE THE NEW TAX
CREDITS AUTHORIZATION IT
GENERATED THREE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN DIRECT
SPENDING ACROSS THE STATE. ONE
POINT FOUR BILLION OF THOSE
DOLLARS HAVE BEEN FOR BELOW THE
LINE WAGES LIKE THOSE FOR COULD
ACCRUE AND PRODUCTION MEMBERS
THESE ARE WELL PAYING TYPICALLY
UNION JOBS VERY VERY IMPORTANT
TO OUR STATE. WELL WE CELEBRATE
OUR SUCCESS WE CANNOT REST ON
OUR LAURELS
WHY BECAUSE WERE FACED WITH
CONTINUING EFFORTS TO LURE FILM
AND CONTENT PRODUCTION
ELSEWHERE.
AND IT IS INCUMBENT UPON
CALIFORNIA TO TAKE STEPS TO
ASSURE THAT WE RETAIN OUR PLACE
AS THE HOME OF THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY.
THAT IS WHY I AM A BIG SUPPORTER
OF AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOUR AND
IT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILL
SEEKS TO DO I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
FIGURE FORMER CHAIR KNOWN WAS
SAPPING TESTIMONY.
TOM
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK
CHAIRPERSON CHU AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE
TODAY.
MONEY IT'S MARK WALTER NOT I
REPRESENT FILMER ISLAND SIMILES.
FILMER ISLAND WAS CREATED ABOUT
TWO YEARS AGO. AND RIGHT NOW IS
COMPRISED OF A NUMBER OF
BUILDINGS ON MARE ISLAND WHICH
IS IN THE CITY OF VALLEJO.
OUR OUR PHASE ONE OF THE PROJECT
WITH TO TAKE THESE OLD NAVY
BUILDINGS.
THAT WERE MOTHBALL FOR MANY
YEARS IMPROVE AND REALIZE THEM.
I'M REALLY PROUD OF THE FACT
THAT WE PUT THE RESOURCES BACK
INTO THESE OLD BUILDINGS.
AND WE'LL BE ABLE TO BRING THEM
BACK TO LIFE.
IT'S BEEN A CATALYST OF
REVITALIZATION FOR THE ENTIRE
AREA.
AND THAT WOULD NEVER HAPPEN IF
IT WAS NOT FOR THE TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE REPURPOSE
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED THAT WITH TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND SQUARE FEET OF
SPACE.
FOR USE BY PRODUCTION COMPANIES.
WE CURRENTLY OTHER HIT PARAMOUNT
TELEVISION PROJECT ON THE
ISLAND.
AND AS NFL'S OTHER LARGE
PRODUCTION SINCE OPENING OUR
DOORS.
INCLUDING A PARAMOUNT FEATURE
FILM PROJECT THIS SUMMER THAT
WAS LOOKING AT GOING TO GEORGIA
BUT DECIDED ON STAINING
CALIFORNIA DUE TO THE TAX
CREDITS.
TOM I GREW UP IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND I'VE BEEN IN THE
STUDIO MANAGEMENT BUSINESS FOR
OVER SEVENTEEN YEARS.
AND DUE TO THE TAX INCENTIVES
AND OTHER STATES SUCH AS GEORGIA
NEW MEXICO LOUISIANA. AND OTHER
COUNTRIES SUCH AS.
CANADA AND THE UK.
NAM.
OFFERING TAX INCENTIVES I'VE
SEEN A MASS EXODUS OF PROJECTS
TO THESE OTHER STATES.
AND UNFORTUNATELY OTHER
COUNTRIES AS WELL.
A LITTLE OVER TWO YEARS AGO
AFTER CALIFORNIA BACK TO THE TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM I BEGIN TO
EXPLORE OPPORTUNITIES IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND WHAT SURPRISE IF THERE WERE
NOT ANY LARGE PURPOSE BUILT
SOUND STAGES IN THE AREA.
WE GET A MARKET STUDY AND
DECIDED THAT WE WOULD FIND A
SUITABLE LOCATION. TEST THE
WATERS AND IF THINGS WORK OUT
BUILT SOME NEW SOUND STAGES.
CURRENTLY WE ARE WAITING FOR THE
CITY TO APPROVE OUR PROPOSAL TO
BILL THREE ADDITIONAL SOUND
STAGES.
AND PRODUCTION SUPPORT
BUILDINGS.
ONCE COMPLETED WE WOULD BE ABLE
TO HAVE MULTIPLE PROJECTS
FILMING AT THE SAME TIME.
WHICH WILL ALLOW US TO COMPETE
WITH STUDIOS ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD.
TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA HOW ONE TV
SHOW CAN MAKE AN IMPACT.
A TV SERIES THIRTEEN REASONS
WHY.
SPEND APPROXIMATELY TWENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN SOLANO IN THE
SURROUNDING COUNTIES DURING
THEIR FIRST SEASON.
IT SHOULD BE IT SHOULD BE NOTED
THAT WE EXPECT THAT PRODUCTION
SPENDING.
DOUBLE THAN TWENTY SEVENTEEN IN
THOSE SAME COUNTIES.
.
ANOTHER REALLY IMPORTANT POINT
IS THAT PRODUCTION HAD APPROX ME
FORTY FIFTY PEOPLE WORKING ON
THE ISLAND WHILE BOTH SHOWS ARE
FILMING IN AUGUST.
NAM.
IN CLOSING.
WE FIND OURSELVES COMPETING WITH
NOT ONLY THE STATES THAT I
MENTIONED BUT OTHER COUNTRIES
ALL OFFERING ATTRACTIVE TAX
INCENTIVES WITHIN ESTABLISH
INFRASTRUCTURE LABOR POOL.
WE NEED THESE TAX CREDITS TO NOT
ONLY CONTINUE BUT ALSO IMPROVE
SO THAT BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE A FAIR SHOT TO BRING
PRODUCTIONS HOME. WHERE IT
BELONGS?
A WE'RE COMMITTED TO INVESTING
IN THE NEEDED INFRASTRUCTURE BUT
WITHOUT THAT CERTAINTY OF THE
TAX INCENTIVE WILL BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO MAINTAIN AND GROW
OUR INDUSTRY.
THE MONEY.
MY NAME IS ALLISON TAYLOR. AND I
THINK MAJORITY LEADER. UP
CALDERON AND CHAIRMAN CHIU AND
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR
INVITING ME HERE TODAY.
I HAVE.
AT WORK DID THE LOCATION
MANAGER FOR OVER TWENTY THREE
YEARS AND I'VE BEEN A MEMBER OF
TEAMSTERS LOCAL THREE NINETY
NINE FOR OVER TWENTY.
THIS ENVIRONMENT IS THEM LOW NEW
TO ME BUT I'M VERY EXCITED TO BE
HERE BECAUSE I FEEL VERY
STRONGLY ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE.
OF THE CURRENT CALIFORNIA FILM
AND TELEVISION TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM. TO POINT NO AND I WANT
TO SPEAK TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOUR.
PRODUCTION PEOPLE OTHER CRAFTS
PEOPLE AND TECHNICIANS THAT WORK
BEHIND THE SCENES TO MAKE WHAT
YOU SEE ON THE SCREEN POSSIBLE.
WE THE PEOPLE THAT YOU NEVER SEE
OR HEAR ABOUT ON THE OSCARS AND
EMMYS.
THEY'RE CLOSE TO ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND OF US LIVING AND
WORKING HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND
WE ARE THE ONES MOST DIRECTLY
IMPACTED WHEN A FILM OR TV
SERIES STAYS IN CALIFORNIA WHEN
IT LEAVES.
I'D LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT AND
EXPLAIN TO YOU EXACTLY WHAT I DO
AS A LOCATION MANAGER AND SCOUT.
THE JOB HAS TWO DISTINCTLY
DIFFERENT COMPONENTS.
THE FIRST IS CREATIVE. COMPONENT
IN THE SECOND OF LOGISTICAL.
AND DURING THE CREATIVE PHASE
OUR JOB IS TO FIND THE LOCATIONS
THAT HELP FULFILL THE DIRECTOR'S
VISION AND MOVE THE STORY
FORWARD.
THE SECOND PHASE IS PURELY
LOGISTICAL OF MUCH LIKE THAT OF
AN EVENT PLANNER. AND IF YOU
WERE TO TREAT EACH LOCATION AS
AN EVENT.
CALIFORNIA.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY ONE OF THE BEST
LOCATIONS IN THE WORLD FOR
FILMING.
THE STATE OFFERS DIVERSE LOOKS
INTO RAINS FROM MOUNTAINS OCEANS
LAKES FOREST AND DESERT.
WE ALSO HAVE THE MOST EXPERIENCE
CREWS.
HOWEVER MOST DECISIONS ABOUT
WHERE TO SHOOT ARE DRIVEN BY
WHERE YOU CAN PRODUCE THE FILM
AT THE LOWEST COST.
MATT'S MY OTHER STATES AND
COUNTRIES HAVE USED THE
INCENTIVES.
TO TAKE PRODUCTION AWAY FROM
CALIFORNIA.
AS A SINGLE MOTHER OF TWO WHO
WAS FORMERLY MARRIED TO A FIRST
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR WHO
CONSTANTLY WORKED OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE ALL OF THE FILMS WERE
BEING SHOT AND STATES AND
COUNTRIES WITH SOME INCENTIVES.
I STAYED AND WORKED IN TOWN IN
ORDER TO RAISE MY CHILDREN.
WHEN THE LOCAL WORK DRIED UP
BEFORE THIS LEGISLATURE PASSED A
BE EIGHTEEN THIRTY NINE.
AND KNOWING THAT LEAVING
CALIFORNIA TO FOLLOW THE WORK
WAS NOT AN OPTION FOR ME.
I WORKED IN A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT INDUSTRY FOR TWO YEARS
BECAUSE I COULD NOT SUPPORT
MYSELF AND MY FAMILY FINANCIALLY
AND THE LOCATION MANAGE.
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES WERE LEFT
UNEMPLOYED. MANY HAD TO LEAVE
THEIR FAMILIES AND TRAVEL TO
OTHER STATES FOR LONG PERIODS OF
TIME TO MAKE A LIVING.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN.
I DID A FEATURE CALLED STRAIGHT
OUTTA COMPTON.
WHEN WE BEGAN PREPPING THE FILM
THE PRODUCERS WERE COMPARING
BUDGETS FOR ATLANTA AND NEW
ORLEANS.
IN ADDITION TO LOS ANGELES
AND THANKS TO A. B. EIGHTEEN
THIRTY NINE WE WERE SELECTED TO
RECEIVE THE TACTIC SENATE. AND
WERE ABLE TO FOUND THE MOVING
CALIFORNIA NOT CAN YOU IMAGINE A
FILM CALLED STRAIGHT OUTTA
COMPTON BEING FILMED IN NEW
ORLEANS BECAUSE WE COULDN'T KEEP
IT IN CALIFORNIA.
WITHIN THREE MONTHS OF ITS
RELEASE THAT FILM ABOUT A LOCAL
CALIFORNIA HIP HOP GROUP HAD
GROSSED OVER TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS WORLD BY.
AND THEN AGAIN IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN. IWORKED
AS A SUPERVISING LOCATION
MANAGER ON A WRINKLE IN TIME.
IN ADDITION TO LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. WE ALSO FOUND IN
HUMBOLDT COUNTY IN INYO COUNTY.
AND IN FACT SOME OF THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL THINGS IN THE FILM WAS
SHOT THE REDWOODS AND HUMBOLDT.
AGAIN I REMEMBER THE DAY THAT WE
WERE INFORMED WE HAVE BEEN
AWARDED THE CALIFORNIA TAX
INCENTIVE.
EVERYONE IN OUR OFFICE WAS
CELEBRATED.
THE PRODUCES ARE HAPPY THAT THEY
COULD STAY HOME WITH THEIR
FAMILIES AND THE REST OF US WERE
HAPPY. THAT WE WOULD HAVE JOBS
FOR THE NEXT NINE MONTHS AND
JUST SO YOU UNDERSTAND. I WOULD
HAVE BEEN REPLACED BY A LOCATION
MANAGER IN ATLANTA BECAUSE THE
PRODUCTION WAS PREPARED TO MOVE
TO GEORGIA HAD WE NOT RECEIVED
ANTHONY.
I WOULD A LOST A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF MY ANNUAL INCOME.
IF THE CALIFORNIA INCENTIVE
PROGRAM DID NOT EXIST.
AND TO ADD A SPECIAL NOTE ABOUT
WRINKLE. THE PROJECT EMPLOYED
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WAS THE MOST INCLUSIVE.
PROJECT I HAD WORKED ON IN MY
ENTIRE CAREER THEIR PEOPLE OF
COLOR WOMEN. AND MEMBERS OF THE
LGBT COMMUNITY ALL PART OF THE
SKILLED TECHNICIANS AND CRAFTS
PEOPLE.
EMPLOYED ON THAT BIG BUDGET
FILM.
AND I BUDGET IN OUR BUSINESS
PRODUCTION DECISIONS AND THEY.
WANTED TO YEARS IN ADVANCE AND
CERTAINTY. IS NEEDED AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOR. THE JOB
CREATOR THAT EXTENDS THE TWO
POINT OH PROGRAM. AND SPEAKING
NOT JUST FOR MYSELF AND MY
FAMILY BUT ALL THE BELOW THE
TIME WOMEN AND WOMEN. WHO WORK
IN THIS BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA?
I THANK YOU IN ADVANCE FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB SEVENTEEN FOUR.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY.
.
HI HELLO.
THANK YOU CHAIRPERSON CHEWING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS AMY LET MISSION I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA FILM COMMISSION WHERE
DEPARTMENT WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. THE FILM COMMISSION
ADMINISTERS THE FILM AND
TELEVISION TAX CREDIT PROGRAM.
THE RITUAL PROGRAM LAUNCHED IN
TWO THOUSAND NINE AND PROGRAM TO
POINT OUT WAS AUTHORIZED FOR
FIVE YEARS BEGINNING IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN. WERE AUTHORIZED
ALLOCATE THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION IN TAX CREDITS
PER FISCAL YEAR.
PRODUCTION DON'T RECEIVE THE
ACTUAL TAX CREDIT CERTIFICATES
THOUGH UNTIL THEY'VE COMPLETED
PRODUCTION AND WE VERIFIED THEIR
AUDIT AND FINAL DOCUMENTATION
THAT.
USUALLY TWELVE TO TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS AFTER THE INITIAL
RESERVATION OF CREDITS.
PERIODS PER FISCAL YEAR AND
PROJECTS ARE SELECTED BASED ON
THEIR JOBS RATIO RANKING WHICH
IS A COMPETITIVE PROCESS WHICH
MEASURES. AREN'T QUALIFIED WAGES
AND OTHER FACTORS THAT AFFECT
ECONOMIC IMPACT WHERE TYPICALLY
OVERSUBSCRIBED IN EACH
APPLICATION PERIOD. A WE
MAINTAIN A WAITING LIST.
IF ANYTHING DROPS OUT THAT THE
PROJECTS ON WAITING LISTS FLIP
FLOPPED. WE RECENTLY COMPLETED
ALL APPLICATION PERIODS FOR THE
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR AND.
IN MY POCKET THAT I GAVE THE
YOU'LL SEE A DETAILED BREAKDOWN
OF THE FIGURES I'M NOT GONNA GO
INTO THAT NOW.
AND IN ADDITION TO LA COUNTY
FILM AND TV PRODUCTIONS IN OUR
PROGRAM HAVE FOUND IN. OUR MANY
COUNTIES CONTRA COSTA HUMBOLDT
MARIN ORANGE RIVERSIDE SAN
PORTANTINO SAN DIEGO SANTA CRUZ
SOLANO AND SONOMA COUNTIES SO
FAR.
AND THE FILM COMMISSION
PUBLISHES AN ANNUAL PROGRESS
REPORT ON THE TAX CREDIT PROGRAM
I'M I DIDN'T GIVE YOU HANDOUTS
IT'S AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE.
AND WE ALSO POST ON OUR WEBSITE
A LIST OF ALL APPROVED PROJECTS
ALONG WITH DETAILS ON THEIR
SPENDING EMPLOYMENT AND TAX
CREDIT ALLOCATIONS. IM HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS FROM.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH I ANY
ADDITIONAL.
UMKC
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF GOODS
KNOWN A V. SEVENTEEN THIRTY PORT
PLEASE COME FOR.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR.
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
WHAT MELISSA PATAK WITH THE
MOTION PICTURE ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICA AGUIAR IN SUPPORT OF AB
I'M SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOUR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALSO ON BEHALF OF
OUR MEMBER COMPANY DISNEY WHO
COULDN'T BE HERE TODAY? IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MELISSA AND MO WITH
SHY ORDER ENTRY ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI IN
TRANSPORT.
THANK YOU.
WHAT ABOUT YOU WITH TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY FOX INSUPPORTABLE? THANK
YOU.
LARA COME BUT WITH THE DIRECTORS
GUILD OF AMERICA IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IF YOU.
SARAH BOOT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SARAH FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN STRONG SUPPORT I
LOVE GOING AFTER THE CHAMBER
WERE BOTH HERE TO GET. YOU.
AT DEATH THE THE TEAMSTERS
LOCAL THREE NINETY NINE IN
SUPPORT AND ALSO AS A BOARD
MEMBER OF FILM LA.
BASE THERE IN SUPPORT AS WELL
THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING JOHN ROSS FOR NBC
UNIVERSAL IN SUPPORT.
I AM SOO CABRAL EBERT.
MAKE A PARTISAN HAIRSTYLES OF
LOCAL SEVEN OH SIX IN SUPPORT.
AND ALSO SPEAKING FOR THE
HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WHO IS ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU.
CHUCK PARKER NATIONAL EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ART DIRECTORS
GUILD LOCAL EIGHT HUNDRED IN
SUPPORT AND ALSO THE RECIPIENT
OF THE BENEFITS IS A PRODUCTION
DESIGNER OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
BOB ANY LOCAL SEVEN TWENTY NINE
SET PAINTERS INSIDER WRITERS IN
SUPPORT.
I STOP IN OUR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF AYE TO SEE LOCAL SIX NINETY
FIVE A REPRESENT PRODUCTION
SOUND AND VIDEO ENGINEERS WHO
WORK ON PRODUCTION. ITS FULL
SUPPORT AND ALSO GO TO THANK FOR
THE PREVIOUS BELLA EXTENDING
FROM MY MEMBERS ARE CURRENTLY
EMPLOYED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IF YOU.
ALEXANDER BUSINESS MANAGER FOR
LIKE YOU KNOW LABOR'S LOCAL
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR. WE ARE
DEFINITELY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
PATRICK ROBERT* IATSE LOCAL
SEVEN TO EIGHT SET LIGHTING AND
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK THANK
YOU.
CASSANDRA HESELTINE PRESIDENT OF
FILM LIAISON TO CALIFORNIA
STATEWIDE AND THE FILM
COMMISSIONER FOR HUMBLE AND ON
OUR COUNTIES AND WHERE IT'S
PART.
THANK YOU.
BEVERLY LEWIS PLASTER LAKE TAHOE
FILM OFFICE AND ON BEHALF OF
PLASTER COUNTY WERE IN SUPPORT
WE'VE HAD FOUR PRODUCTIONS UNDER
THIS INCENTIVE PROGRAM THANK
YOU.
HI KERRY WOULD SAG AFTER ALMOST
NINETY THOUSAND MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
VERY BROAD CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JASON MCLEOD BUSINESS
REPRESENTED FOR THE ANIMATION
GUILD IATSE LOCAL EIGHT THIRTY
NINE OF MY FOUR THOUSAND MEMBER
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
BUT AT THE GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CALLUSES EATEN IN
SUPPORT.
IF YOU.
KERRY MUST GET WITH VISITS
SACRAMENTO THE SACRAMENT OF FILM
COMMISSION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU.
REBECCA ROMIJN NATIONAL
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
INTERNATIONAL CINEMATOGRAPHERS
GUILD IATSE LOCAL SIX HUNDRED IN
VERY STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KATHY GARMAN Z. ON BEHALF OF THE
ENTERTAINMENT UNION COALITION
WHICH REPRESENTS THE HUNDRED
THOUSAND WORKING MEN AND WOMEN
WHO BENEFIT FROM THIS BILL
INSTRUCTS.
THANK YOU.
AT BROWN OF IDEAS SEE LOCAL
FORTY FOUR REPRESENTING SIX
THOUSAND MOTION PICTURE AND
TELEVISION WORKERS EARLIER IN
CALIFORNIA AND I WANNA THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PREVIOUS SUPPORT. AND
YOUR FURTHER SUPPORT AND HELPING
TO BRING BACK THE CALIFORNIA
HUNDREDS OF MY MEMBERS WHO MOVED
AWAY CHASING. UP PRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU.
A KILL COME MEANS I'M A TRUMPET
PLAYER AND PRESIDENT OF THE
LOCAL. OUR MUSICIANSHIP AND
LOCAL SIX IN SAN FRANCISCO. ON
BEHALF OF ALL MUSICIANS AND
MUSICIANS UNION HANDS IN
CALIFORNIA WEIRD STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S MARK SAYS I'M A
VIOLINIST TIME A MUSICIAN ALSO I
WONDER IF I KNOW YOU HAVE A LONG
DAY IF I COULD READ A BRIEF
STATEMENT IN SUPPORT.
WHO DID PLEASE JUST A STATE YOUR
NAME AND ASSOCIATION THINK HERE
OKAY MIGHTMY NAME'S MARK CESAR
I'M A MEMBER OF LOCAL FORTY
SEVEN MERIT AMERICAN FEDERATION
OF MUSICIANS IN LOS ANGELES
INSUBORDINATE MUCH?
CARLA SALES OF WARNER BROTHERS
ENCHANTMENT ONE SPORT THANK YOU.
I HAVE JIMBO MY PRESIDENT OF
LOCAL SIXTEEN IN SAN FRANCISCO
ALSO FILM COMMISSIONER SAN
FRANCISCO AND WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YEAH
TOM DAVIS BUSINESS MANAGER
RIGHTEOUSLY LOCAL ATM PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA TNC COUNCIL
SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
BOB I AND COMPOSITION PRESENT OF
LOCUSTS SEVERAL FIVE MOTION
PICTURE CUSTOMERS.
A A BEHALF MY TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED MEMBERS WE SAID I WOULD
SUPPORT THE SPELL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ANY ERA A ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
THESE COME FORWARD.
XENON ANY OPPOSITION.
ABOUT FIVE PEOPLE IN THE ROOM TO
HAVE BEEN SPOKEN YET.
YEAH I WOULD JUST.
MOVE ON TO. THE MEMBERS
TESTIMONY.
IT ALL QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I WAS ON THE
COMMITTEE WHEN WE SUPPORTED IT.
THE FIRST TIME AROUND AND.
THE LITTLE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON
IT SO I ASKED TO BE A COAUTHOR.
THINK YOU.
COURSE.
THANK YOU FOR A VICE CHAIR ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENT.
MEMBER CHIU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE MEMBERS
THE PUBLIC AND THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND LET ME
FIRST START BY SAYING THAT I'VE
BEEN A LONG TIME SUPPORTER. OF
THIS FILM TAX CREDIT BEFORE I
WAS ELECTED TO THE LEGISLATURE
ARE ACTUALLY JOINT AND SPOKE AT
RALLIES ON BEHALF OF MY CITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO. WHICH UNTIL
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA THAT
RECEIVED.
THE MOST BUSINESS FROM THIS
INDUSTRY.
GIVEN THE VANTAGE POINTS
INVESTORS THAT WE HAVE IN MY
DISTRICT.
THAT BEING SAID FOR THE BETTER
PART OF ABOUT FIFTEEN YEARS I
HAVE WORKED CLOSELY WITH MANY
DIVERSE MEMBERS OF THE
ENTERTAINMENT COMMITTEE HAVE
COMMUNITY. OPTICALLY FROM THE
API COMMUNITY WHO HAVE WISHED.
THAT THE INDUSTRY COULD BE MORE
SUPPORTIVE OF.
WORKERS AND EMPLOYEES OF OF
COLOR.
AND EVERY TIME I GOT LA I
GENERALLY END UP IN A
CONVERSATION LIKE THIS NOT JUST
PROVIDE ONE ANECDOTE TWO YEARS
AGO THE NIGHT MY. SON WAS BORN
MY SON IS CHINESE ARE THE OSCARS
ARE HIGHLIGHTED.
BROUGHT THREE.
A YOUNG CHINESE KIDS UP TO THE
STAGE AND PROCEEDED TO
STEREOTYPE THEM AYE AND THAT WAS
PART OF THE BEGINNING OF A
CONVERSATION OF THE OSCARS SO
WHITE MOVEMENT.
I ALSO WANNA JUST TAKE A MOMENT
AND REFERENCE SOME OF THE.
TESTIMONY IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS.
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT BELOW THE
LINE JOBS.
MISMANAGED FROM THE CALIFORNIA
FILM COMMISSION HAVE PROVIDED
SOME STATISTICS ABOUT HOW.
AFRICAN AMERICANS ONLY GOT FOUR
PERCENT OF THE BELOW THE LINE
JOBS CREATED DURING THE FIRST
PHASE OF THE FILM TAX INCENTIVE
PROGRAM. ASIAN AMERICANS ONLY
GOT TWO PERCENT OF THOSE JOBS
NATIVE AMERICANS GOT ONE PERCENT
WOMAN ONLY RECEIVED TWENTY NINE
PERCENT LATINOS LANDED ELEVEN
PERCENT.
CLEARLY WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK
TO DO ARM AND I WANNA THANK THE
AUTHOR BECAUSE I KNOW MISTER
CALDERON HAS BEEN WORKING WITH.
THE CHAIR OF THE API CAUCUS
MISTER BONTA AND OTHERS AND.
AND I'M SORRY I'M ACTUALLY
SUPPOSED TO BE INTO OTHER
COMMITTEES AT THIS MOMENT BUT I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU REFERENCED
SOME OF WHAT YOU'RE HOPING TO
ACHIEVE WITH THIS YEAR'S TAX
CREDIT.
I I RAISE THIS BECAUSE I
CONTINUE TO HEAR A LOT OF
FEEDBACK AND SUGGESTIONS ABOUT
WHAT MORE WE CAN DO. AND.
I HAVE REALLY QUESTION BUT I
ALSO WANT TO JUST MAKE THE
COMMENT THAT I THINK THERE IS
MUCH MORE WE SHOULD DO. ARE MY
HOPE IS THIS DISCUSSION WILL
CONTINUE AND.
I KNOW THAT I'M WORKING WITH
MISTER BARTON OTHERS TO CONTINUE
TO SOLICIT GOOD IDEAS THAT WE
CAN HOPEFULLY PROPOSED TO THE
AUTHOR. TO ADDRESS THIS.
TO ADDRESS NOT JUST THE BELOW
THE LINE DYNAMIC BUT YOU KNOW I
UNDERSTAND THIS TAX CREDIT IS
REALLY FOCUSED ON THAT. BUT FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE.
WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
IMPACT ABOUT THE LINE
AND.
AND WHILE THIS IS A TAX CREDIT
FOCUSED IN ONE PART OF THE
SECTOR.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY OUR WAY TO
ENSURE THAT HOPEFULLY THE
INDUSTRY CONTINUES TO MOVE IN
THAT DIRECTION SO AM I WANT TO
SAY THAT I WILL CERTAINLY BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TO MOVE OUT
OF COMMITTEE TODAY BUT I AM
GOING TO RESERVE MY VOTE. FOR
THE FLOOR IN HOPES THAT THE
CONVERSATIONS CONTINUE IN A
POSITIVE DIRECTION I HAD THE
SAME COMMENTS FOR MISTER NEWS
AARON'S BILL BUT I ALSO WANT AND
JUST ASK YOU AUTHOR AND ANYONE
ELSE WHO IS HERE. WHAT OTHER
IDEAS HAVE THEIR BAND TO MOVE
THINGS FORWARD BELOW THE LINE
AND WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
HOW WE CAN IMPACT?
AT THE DIVERSITY CHALLENGES
THAT WE CERTAINLY SEE ABOVE THE
LINE
SO THANK YOU AFTER YOUR
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
THE BILL OUT WE HAD A REALLY BIG
MEETING BETWEEN.
THE JOINT AUTHORS OF THE BILL'S
WALLS THE ENTIRE COALITION TO
TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW SOME OF THE
ISSUES AROUND DIVERSITY AND I AM
YOU MISTER BONTA ATTENDED THE
MEETING MISTER BONTA EARLY ON.
HAD ASKED TO BE A PART OF THE
DISCUSSIONS ARE SPEAKING
DIRECTLY TO DIVERSITY IN ALL
OBVIOUS WE WERE MORE THAN HAPPY
TO HAVE HIM THERE TO BE A PART
OF THIS.
PROBLEM SOLVING GROUP THAT WERE
PART OF RIGHT NOW.
YOU KNOW THAT THE PROBLEM THAT
HAS ALWAYS EXISTED.
AROUND ADVERSITY HAS BEEN MORE
CENTERED AROUND THE INABILITY
FOR UP FOR.
DOT LOOK THEY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES EVERS COMMUNITIES TO
BE ABLE TO KIND HAVE THIS.
PATHWAY INTO THE.
INTO THE INDUSTRY AYE AND SO WE
CREATED THIS CAREER PATHWAYS
TRAINING PROGRAM.
TO GO DIRECTLY AFTER A LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES A TO GO AFTER
A HOT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR TO
NOT CREATE AN INTERNSHIP PROGRAM
BUT TO HAVE A PROGRAM THAT'S
GOING TO BE FUNDED BY THOSE THAT
ARE BEING. CAN BE RECIPIENTS OF
THE FILM TAX CREDIT THAT ARE
BENEFITING. UP FROM STATE
INCENTIVIZE DE STATE INCENTIVES
OB CONTRIBUTORS PROGRAM TO GET
THEM JOB TRAINING ARE AND THAT'S
REALLY KIND OF BEEN THE PROBLEM
OUT WHEN IT COMES TO GETTING
MORE. DAD DIVERSE COMMUNITIES AT
IN ENGAGED IN THIS NSR THAT IN
THE SECTOR SO WE REALLY BELIEVE
THAT THE CAREER PATHWAYS
TRAINING PROGRAM IS GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT WILL ALLOW US TO.
TO BRING MORE DIVERSITY INTO THE
INDUSTRY AYE IT'S GONNA BE
SOMETHING THAT EVERY.
FACET OF THIS INDUSTRY FROM THE
STUDIOS TO TO ALL OF THE LABOR
UNIONS ARE BELOW THE LINE
WORKERS ARE GOING TO BEING GAY
ASIAN.
YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD A COUPLE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT ABOUT THE
LINE UP THERE ARE DIFFERENT
ISSUES THAT WE FACE IN THE
WEATHER'S PROP TWO ON NINE
ISSUES INCENTIVIZE OKAY WE WANT
TO BE OF THAT SENT VICE IF YOU
HIRE WOMAN TO BE A DIRECTOR OF
THE PROJECT. WELL WHAT DOES THAT
DO IN TERMS OF PROP TWO ONE NINE
IN AND SPECIFICALLY OF MANAGING
ONE GROUP OVER THE OTHER. AYE
AND SO NOW WE'VE HAD A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHAT WE CAN
DO.
WE HAVE ALWAYS STAYED OPEN AND
WILL COMMIT A WAS CONTINUE TO
STAY OPEN TO NEW IDEAS.
BUT I I I I WELCOME HELP I WAS
WITH YOU.
WHEN YOU WERE SUPERVISOR WHEN
WE WERE WHEN WE WERE UP IN THAT
FILM NOR CAL ARE MAKING THE THE
YOU HAD THE PITCH TO TO GET
EIGHTEEN THIRTY NINE PASS AND SO
I APPRECIATED YOUR SUPPORT BACK
THEN I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT NOW. ARE AND YOU KNOW WE
HAVE A CLOSE RELATIONSHIP SO IF
YOU HAVE ANY IDEAS I'M MORE THAN
HAPPY TO PRESENT THOSE IDEAS TO
THE COALITION TO TRYING TO AS
MUCH SUPPORT AS POSSIBLE. BUT
AGAIN WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
TOGETHER.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU IF IF I COULD
JUST ABOUT ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE PANEL ON THIS TOPIC.
WE HAVE IT WE HAVE A PROGRAM
WITH SOLANO COUNTY WORKFORCE
BOARD.
AND IT'S FOR THAT AT RISK YOUTH
THAT ARE IN DANGER OF NOT
GRADUATING. SO WE BRING A MAN WE
GIVEN TRAINING DALIAN.
GRIPPING LIGHTING BUT ALSO ON
STAGE MANAGEMENT. SO I'M I'M A
LITTLE GUY SO I I CAN ONLY HIRE
COUPLE GUYS AT A TIME BUT IT'S A
VERY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM. IN THE
CITY OF VALLEJO AND BAD AREAS.
IT'S ALL. REALLY DIVERSE SO MOST
OF THE.
IT'S COMING UP PROGRAM.
ARTS OR SOME THE GROUP THAT
SHOULD MENTION.
IT GETS IN THE AND JUST BE CLEAR
TO YOU ON THE CAREER PATHWAYS
THAT I'D ACTUALLY HAS GONE THAT
I AYE SIDETRACK MYSELF. IS.
THAT DID THIS ISN'T AN
INTERNSHIP IT IS SOMETHING THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO BE PAID TO DO I
AND YOU'RE GONNA BE BEING
TRAINED AS I CAN IMPRESS AS AN
APPRENTICESHIP. BEING TRAINED BY
THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE THE
BEST IN THE IN THE BUSINESS.
SO REGARDLESS OF WHATEVER I THE
FAST OF THE INITIAL YOU CHOOSE
TO GO AND YOU CAN BE BEING
TRAINED BY THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE
THAT ARE. THE BEST AT WHAT THEY
DO TO GET THAT EXPERIENCE OUGHT
TO THEN BE SOMEBODY THAT'S GOING
TO BE ABLE TO MOVE INTO THE
INDUSTRY.
IF I COULD JUST A COUPLE
COMMENTS ON THAT SIR VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE.
THE AUTHORS.
UNDERSTANDING APPRECIATION OF
THIS ISSUE AND I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO BE ENGAGE WITH YOU AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS. I DO
THINK.
THAT WHILE.
ENSURING THERE'S A BIG ENOUGH
PATHWAY IS ONE ASPECT OF THE
PROBLEM AND FOCUSING ON.
ON ON LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
AND SO CALLED AT RISK
COMMUNITIES IMPORTANT. I HAVE
HEARD.
AT LENGTH FROM MANY MEMBERS
WITHIN THE INDUSTRY WHO MAY NOT
CONSIDER THEMSELVES SO CALLED AT
RISK CURVE LOW INCOME
BACKGROUNDS WHO REPRESENT.
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES WHO'VE BEEN
WORKING AND TOILING IN THE
INDUSTRY WHO CANNOT SEEM TO
BREAK INTO. THE BUSINESSES THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
WHETHER BECAUSE OF NETWORKS
THAT ARE CLOSE TO THEM OR
SOMEHOW PERCEPTION THAT AMERICAN
THE WORLD MAY NOT WANT TO SEE
CERTAIN TYPES OF FILMS. ARE AND
CERTAIN TYPES OF STORIES IN THIS
IS A THIS IS A VERY COMMON AND
NO DISCUSSION THAT'S HAPPENING
AND HAS BEEN HAPPENING THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS BUT MY HOPE IS
THAT.
IN ADDITION TO PATHWAYS WE CAN
THINK ABOUT OTHER WAYS OF OF
EXPANDING ACCESS.
AS A FORMER CIVIL RIGHTS
ATTORNEY I'M CERTAINLY AWARE.
OF THE CHALLENGES YOU MENTION
AROUND PROP TO A NINE AND AND
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE IDEAS THAT
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED BUT. I AM I
CONTINUE TO HAVE SO MANY
CONVERSATIONS AND REALLY EVERY
TIME I GO DOWN LA AND MEET WITH.
DIVERSE MEMBERS OF THE INDUSTRY
IT'S JUST WHAT I CONTINUE TO
HEAR AND THERE IS A ONGOING
PERCEPTION THAT THIS TAX CREDIT
IS NOT GOING TO MOVE THE NEEDLE
WITH REGARD TO THAT AND I KNOW
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT SO. LOOK FOR
TO THE CONVERSATION AND AGAIN
THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR WORK
AND AND AND GOOD THOUGHTS ON
THIS TOPIC THEY GIVE SOME
IMMATURE AND AM IN AND THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME WE'VE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION I MEAN THE PROGRAM
IS RELATIVELY NEW. BUT WE
RECOGNIZE THE DEFICIENCIES WHEN
IT
SO ISSUES
OF LIKE DIVERSITY AND THIS IS
WHY WE'RE HAVING A VERY SERIOUS
CONVERSATION ON THIS ARE. WE
REALLY DO APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS AND AND THAT IS NOT
FALLING ON DEAF EARS.
RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHAUNA
MEMBER FREEMAN.
IF I.
APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I SPENT.
OVER TWENTY YEARS MY ENTIRE
CAREER IN THE FILM INDUSTRY.
WORKING AS A PRODUCER AND A
DEVELOPMENT EXECUTIVE I'VE
ALWAYS WORKED ABOUT THE LINE
I'VE NEVER WORKED BELOW THE
LINE.
AND I LOOK AT THE.
DIVERSITY ISSUES ACTUALLY FROM
A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT LANCE
COMING FROM THE EXECUTIVE RANKS.
AND I THINK THAT THE CHALLENGES
WITH THE WORK FORCE PIVOTAL
LINER I BELIEVE ACTUALLY MUCH
EASIER SOLVE THAT ABOVE THE
LINE.
AND YOU KNOW I COULD TALK FOR A
LONG TIME ABOUT WHAT THAT'S.
NO MY FEELINGS ABOUT THAT IN MY
PERSPECTIVES ON IT BUT IT'S NOT
REALLY RELEVANT TO A YOU KNOW
THAT PART TO THIS BILL I DON'T
THINK THAT YOU CAN SOLVE ANY OF
THAT THROUGH THIS KIND OF A
VEHICLE AND I WOULDN'T EXPECTED
TO. I CAN TELL YOU THOUGH IT
COMING FROM A DISTRICT THAT HAS
A WITHIN IT FOR MAJOR FILM
STUDIOS. AND WHERE A PART OF ME
VAST MAJORITY OF RESIDENTS WORK
EITHER DIRECTLY IN THE INDUSTRY
OR IN SOME ANCILLARY ROLE I CAN
TELL YOU THAT THE. PREVIOUS
INCARNATION OF THE TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM HAS BEEN NOTHING SHORT
OF YOU KNOW A MONUMENTAL CHANGE
FROM WHAT WE HAD SEEN BEFORE.
AND THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN MY
COMMUNITY WHO ARE NOW WORKING
SUBTLY IN LOS ANGELES WHO WERE
EITHER TRAVELING OR. AS YOU SAID
DENIED THE ABILITY TO WORK AT
ALL BECAUSE OF CREWS YOU KNOW A
LOT OF CREWS BEING ABLE TO BE
HIRED NOW IN A LOT OF THE COMMON
LOCATIONS.
I'M HAS MADE A HUGE DIFFERENCE
IN PEOPLE'S LIVES IN PEOPLE'S
ABILITY TO PUT FOOD ON THEIR
TABLE. NAM MOVE THEIR CAREERS
FORWARD I'M AFFORD TO LIVE IN
WHAT'S INCREASINGLY A HOT YOU
KNOW VERY DIFFICULT.
.
A CITY TO PAY FOR RENT AND ALL
OF THE OTHER THINGS IT TAKES TO
LIVE IN LOS ANGELES I'M THIS IS
BEEN A REAL LIFE LINE. TO THE
PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT YOU KNOW
THAT THE FILM INDUSTRY IS IS
DIFFERENT THAN A LOT OF OTHER
INDUSTRIES BESIDES BEING.
YOU KNOW A HUGE INDUSTRY AROUND
LOS ANGELES IT'S ALSO OUR
SIGNATURE INDUSTRY
IT'S WHAT PEOPLE THINK OF WHEN
THEY THINK OF CALIFORNIA WHEN I
THINK OF LOS ANGELES. IT IMPACTS
EVERYTHING TOURISM THE IMAGE OF
OUR STATE ARM THE DREAMS OF OUR
CHILDREN I CAME TO LOS ANGELES
IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO BECAUSE I
GOT A JOB AT A FILM STUDIO. I
HAVE BEEN WORKING AT A STUDIO IN
NEW YORK.
IF.
IT HAD BEEN A DIFFERENT TIME IN
THERE HAVE BEEN MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO NEW YORK I
MIGHT HAVE STAYED THERE I'M VERY
GLAD THAT I CAME TO LOS ANGELES
AND MADE THAT CHANGE AND I WANT
TO BE ABLE TO.
MAKE SURE THAT LOS ANGELES
CONTINUES TO BE THE PLACE THAT
DRAWS PEOPLE BECAUSE OF THEIR
DREAMS.
I DO HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU
AND IT HAS TO DO WITH THE OTHER
BILL THAT'S GOING TO BE
PRESENTED TODAY WHICH IS ALSO A.
.
TAX CREDIT BILL AND I THINK I'LL
ADDRESS THIS TO MR BLOOM BECAUSE
YOU'RE AN AUTHOR ON BOTH BILLS.
BUT ON MAYBE YOU CAN EXPLAIN TO
ME A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TWO. SO
THAT I UNDERSTAND NOT TO
PREPARED TO DO THAT THIS MORNING
BUT I THINK THAT.
THESE ARE BILLS THAT SHOULD BE
RECONCILED WITH ONE ANOTHER.
OF THEY'RE BOTH IMPORTANT
EFFORTS
AND I'M HOPEFUL THAT WE'LL BE
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THAT.
OKAY.
I'M PREPARED TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL TODAY ARE PRETTY
ENTHUSIASTICALLY I WOULD HUMBLY
REQUEST TO BE ADDED AS AN
AUTHORED SOME POINT IF THAT'S
POSSIBLE.
AND AGAIN I THINK YOU FOR
WORKING SO CLOSELY WITH THE
INDUSTRY TO IT YOU KNOW ADDRESS
THE CONCERN TO MAKE THIS EVEN A
BETTER VEHICLE GOING FORWARD.
MAKE YOU SOME IN THE FRIEDMAN.
SECULAR MUCH CHAU MEMBER ACOSTA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND LIKE
MS FRIEDMAN I HAVE AN EXTENSIVE.
BACKGROUND.
SOMEWHAT PERSONALLY BUT MOSTLY
THROUGH MY FAMILY IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY.
.
I AM A PROUD MEMBER SAG AFTER
OTHER THEY'RE STILL IN THE BACK
SOMEWHERE IT WILL PLUG HERE.
FOR GUILD BITES.
YOU KNOW I GREW UP IN THE
INDUSTRY AS SOME OF YOU KNOW MY
FATHER WAS.
YOU'RE KIND OF A GROUNDBREAKING
GUY IN LATINO CHARACTER ACTING
OF YOU KNOW BASICALLY FROM THE
FORTIES ON.
AND YOU KNOW IT TO SEE THE
INDUSTRY YOU KNOW GETS A
BIFURCATED THE WAY IT HAS OVER
THE YEARS AND MOVE ALL OVER THE
US ALL OVER THE COUNTRY. I'VE
WATCHED AS FRIENDS AND FAMILY
MEMBERS
STRUGGLE TO HAVE THEIR FAMILIES
HERE AND THEIR FRIEND EXCUSE ME
THEIR JOBS.
IN ATLANTA OR WERE AT WHEREVER.
ATLANTA TORONTO ON MY WIFE'S
COUSIN IS BEEN IN CANADA
PROBABLY MORE THAT SHE'S BEEN IN
THE IN THE U. S..
AND THAT'S YOU KNOW THAT
CAMILLE BUT FRUSTRATING SO I
PLOP PLOP THIS EFFORT.
BOB AND I APPLAUD THE FACT THAT
YOU KNOW MY COLLEAGUES ARE
BRINGING UP ISSUES THAT ARE
IMPORTANT YOU KNOW SOMEONE WHO
WATCHED.
MY FATHER GET A LITTLE BIT
PERTURBED WHEN HE GOT VERY ILL
OF RIGHT BEFORE SHOOTING AND
THEY REPLACED HIM WITH A MEXICAN
ROLE WITH THE JEWISH GUY MET
JEWISH GUY DID A PHENOMENAL JOB.
BUT HE WAS YOU KNOW JOKINGLY
SAYING YOU KNOW ALL THE ALL THE
MEXICANS IN HOLLYWOOD ELIMINATE
THEY CASTED YOU IN MY ROLE YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
AND AND THE BY THE WAY.
ELI WALLACH A LOT WHEN I THE
YOU KNOW THE BEEB KNOWN FOR THAT
ROLE BY THE WAY A DOES ANYBODY
KNOW YOU WELL STEEL AYE WILK WAS
JEWISH OKAY.
WELL HE WAS AN ITALIAN ANY
WASN'T MEXICAN IN THE IN THE
MAGNIFICENT SEVEN AND I'M I'M
ONLY I'M ONLY YOU KNOW YOU HAVE
KIDDING HERE BUT. WHAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT IS THAT WE GET QUALITY
TALENT.
AND WHAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT IS
THAT THERE ARE GOOD QUALITY
PEOPLE OUT THERE IN THIS
INDUSTRY BUT THEY'RE NEVER GOING
TO GET AN OPPORTUNITY.
AS MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID AND
WE HAD A MEETING IN LOS ANGELES
WITH ABOUT. TWELVE.
LEGISLATORS MANY OF US ON THIS
COMMITTEE.
A ABOUT THIS VERY ISSUE WOMEN.
ABOVE THE LINE.
OTHER MINORITIES MONTH ON THE
LINE ABOVE THE LINE AT BUT ALSO
BELOW THE LINE JOBS AND IS
ANYBODY THAT CAN TELL YOU WHEN
YOU HEARD IT TODAY VERY
SUCCINCTLY.
LOCATION SCOUTS TALENT SCOUTS
MAKE UP WHEN I WENT ON OF US
THAT. AND I I HAVE A LITTLE CO
STARRING ROLE OR I WAS THE LEAD
IN THE COMMERCIAL I TURNED
AROUND IN THIS THREE HUNDRED
PEOPLE BEHIND ME.
AND THOSE ARE THE THREE HUNDRED
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
INLAND EMPIRE IT SECTOR THAT ARE
WORKING DAY IN AND DAY OUT.
THE TOP BILLED ACTORS THEY'RE
FINE
PRODUCERS DIRECTORS THEY'RE FINE
THIS ISN'T ABOUT THEM SO MUCH.
IT'S ABOUT THOSE FOLKS THAT MADE
THEIR CAREER AND STATE THEIR
LIVES HERE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
AND AND I REALLY OF.
IT AM PROUD TO BE APART OF.
AND AUTHOR ON THE OTHER A BILL
THAT WILL HERE A FEW MINUTES AND
I AND I
YEAH THANK YOU FOR YOUR OFFER TO
ALLOW ME TO. AUTHOR THIS BILL AS
WELL.
BUT.
I I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S CLEAR FOR THE RECORD THAT
WE'RE REALLY TALKING ABOUT
EVERYONE HERE
AND EVERYONE HERE NEEDS TO HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY.
AND I AND I'M REALLY GLAD TO
HEAR ABOUT MY COLLEAGUE OF SAN
FRANCISCO BRING UP VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUES.
BECAUSE THOSE ISSUES ARE THE
KINDS OF THINGS THATWILL NET
THIS INDUSTRY TOGETHER AND IT
WILL NEED IT IN THE FUTURE TO
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA TO THE REST THE
STATE.
BECAUSE OUR STATE IS SO DIVERSE
BUT LET'S GET THE JOBS LET'S
KEEP THE JOBS HERE.
AND THEN WE CAN YOU KNOW MASSAGE
THE DIFFERENCES ARE I'M SURE
THESE BILLS WILL BE RECONCILED
AS WE GO FORWARD. I DID HAVE A
QUICK QUESTION.
AND IT'S PROBABLY JUST A AYOU
KNOW YES FROM YOU PROBABLY BUT
IT LOOKS TO ME I'M REALLY HAPPY
TO SEE BECAUSE THEY MET WITH A
CAME TO MY OFFICE AND IT WITH ME
AND THAT'S THE.
THE.
MUSICIANS GLAD TO SEE THAT'S IN
THE BILL.
MOVIE STUDIOS RANCHES WERE NOT
WERE PRETTY ALL INCLUSIVE IN
THIS BILL THAT'S CORRECT YES IT
IS TO WANT TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
THAT ON THE RECORD. THANK YOU SO
MUCH I LOOK FORWARD TO OUR BEING
ADDED AS AN AUTHOR AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING THE OTHER THE
OTHER BILL. BIG UP BIG TIME IN
SUPPORT OF THIS OF THIS
LEGISLATION TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BUT IT WAS CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CLASSROOM.
SINCE I'M THE ONLY ONE ON THE
PANEL NOW NOT SPEAKING I I I
WANTED TO AT LEAST.
SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
WORK I APPRECIATE THAT THEIR
SUCH A VIBRANT INTEREST.
AND IN MAKING SURE THAT THIS
INDUSTRY IS NOT ONLY PRESERVED
BUT ALSO THRIVES BECAUSE WE HAVE
LOST QUITE A BIT OF JOBS AND.
THE DISPLACEMENT OF FAMILIES A
HAS IMPACTED ESPECIALLY IN
CERTAIN DISTRICTS SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE THAN OTHERS UMP EVERY WHEN
I WAS CAMPAIGNING IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE EVERY OTHER DOOR
I'D KNOCK ON. A SPECIAL IN
STUDIO CITY IT'S EITHER
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY OR
REALTORS. AND THE AND THE THEY
KNOW WHERE TO BUY.
AND AND THE BUT WHAT WAS REALLY
DIFFICULT TO SEE WAS.
I EVERY TIME IT WAS AN
ENTERTAINMENT HOME OF ONE OF THE
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO WOULD. A NOT
BE HOME AND THEY WERE GONNA THEY
WERE AWAY FOR EITHER A STRETCH
OF A THREE MONTH TO SIX MONTH.
PERIOD A SOMEWHERE IN THE EAST
COAST AND OR OR SOUTHEAST.
SO.
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
PERSONALLY VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT HAS A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT SO A AND IT'S I'M GLAD TO
SEE THAT THERE ARE FOUR
DIFFERENT MEMBERS ACTUALLY
CARING ENOUGH ABOUT THIS. TO ONE
OF PUSH THIS FORWARD AND WITH
THE MULTIPLE CO AUTHORS AND THE
VARIOUS INTERESTS FROM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AS WELL
BECAUSE. THE ECONOMIC BENEFIT
THAT COMES BACK GOES INTO THE
GENERAL FUNDS.
WHICH ALSO ENHANCES OTHER
PROGRAMS AND OPPORTUNITIES
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO.
EDUCATION SO.
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOT
DETRACT FROM THESE EFFORTS BUT
NOT HELP CONTINUE. BUILDING IT.
BECAUSE SAID THE NEW NORM IS
GONNA BE THAT THERE ARE SOME
OTHER STATES AFTER THE DUST
SETTLES.
THERE ARE GONNA BE SEVERAL
STATES THAT WERE NOT A KEY
PLAYER IN THIS INDUSTRY BUT
UNFORTUNATELY NOW ARE.
AND THAT'S PARTIALLY BECAUSE OF
THE LACK OF INACTION.
OF THIS BODY FROM.
TWENTY YEARS AGO.
SO I'M GLAD TO SEE THIS
MOVEMENT AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE EVERYONE
INVOLVED.
BUT YOU SUMMIT MEMBER. VICTOR
MATURE MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENT FROM THE MEMBERS.
ON BEING THE ALLOWED.
I DID HOWEVER THING HAS BEEN
SET.
BUT THE UP ON I THINK YOU VERY
MUCH OF FORMER CHAIR FOR
BRINGING THIS OVER IN MANY OF
YOUR. OF PRINCE VOCAL AUTHORS.
BOB.
I HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO WENT
DOWN TO LOS ANGELES TWICE
ONE IS WITH THE IT THAT.
TO.
CHAIR ALTHOUGH REVENUE AND TAX.
SEBASTIAN.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE WERE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND DE HOW SUCCESSFUL
THIS FILM ACTUAR THAT WORKED.
ANTO WOULD VERY PLEASE AND THAT.
BAD IT WORKS REALLY REALLY WELL
FOR CALIFORNIA SO I WON'T TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY ALSO
CONGRATULATE. ALL OF YOU DATA
WHO WORK IN THE FILM INDUSTRY
FOR A STRONG COMING BACK TO
CALIFORNIA.
AND THE SECOND TRIP I TOOK WAS
WITH THE A DAVID AND I ROB BONTA
ON THE API CALL BECAUSE TO HEAR.
OF A LOT OF THE  API.
.
YEAH ACT ACTOR ACTORS AND OF OF
PRODUCERS. OR WANNABE DIRECTORS
AND SO ON AND SO FORTH.
OF HADERA CONCERN OF NOT BEING
NOT.
HELPING OF. WHO IS FAIR?
OPPORTUNITY AND FAIR A CHANCE TO
BE.
EXCEPT FOR IN AN HOLLYWOOD SO I
DO OUT COLD.
BUT THAT DAVID WAS JUST SAT A
VIAL OF THE STATE THAT DID
DIVIDE DIVERSITY ISSUE. AND I'M
DEFINITELY VERY COMMITTED TO IT
AND BE CONTINUE A WORKING WITH
THE INDUSTRY AND MAKE SURE THAT
THE.
.
THAT INDUSTRY REFLECT TO THE
DIVERSITY OFF OUR STATE.
AND BUT BUT BUT I WOULD WHICH
HAD I WON THE THING HE AUTHOR
FOR ADDING THIS ARE CARILLO PAST
TRAINING PROGRAM.
YOU KNOW TO DISPEL AYE I THINK
HOPEFULLY OVER THE YEARS WHO
WILL BE ABLE TO.
OF A BUILD UP MORE. OF OUR
EXPERTISE IN THE IN THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY AS WELL
AS TO YOUR A DIVERSE YOU COMING
HERE. AND ALSO ON THE THANK YOU
ON HIM FOR BEING TAKEN A OAK.
ADDING THE MUSICIAN.
PART TO TO TO DISPEL COULD STAY
CAME AND TALKED TO MEETINGS
EXPRESSED A CONCERN.
ABOUT NOT BEING ABLE TO.
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE FILM
CRIED. SO OVERALL THING USER
REALLY REALLY OF GREAT BILL I BE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT. AND I KNOW
WOULD HAVE ANOTHER ONE COMING
UP.
AND HOPEFULLY WAR WAS BUT AS WE
MOVE FOR. A LONG WOULD BE ABLE
TO CONSOLIDATE. INTO ONE INTO
EVEN BETTER BUILT SO WAS THAT.
LIKE TO PLEASE ASK FEE BUT
ANSWER ACCRUED TO CALDERON.
G. AT YOU MENTAL CLOSE SORRY.
BURBANK YOU SOME LOS MOST EPO
AND AND MEMBERS I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT TIME I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS I'LL
SERGEANT AYE VOTE ON THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HIS AREAS BUILT
IMPORTANT ALWAYS KEEP THE
CONVERSATION.
MOVING ALONG AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH HIM IN THE
FUTURE ARE AND I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY.
WHO CAME THERE TO BE A PART OF
THIS YOU CAME TO BE A WITNESS
GREAT JOB?
ALSO MY JOINT AUTHORS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS BLOOM LAUREN GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AS WELL AS BONTA
FOR THEIR WORK BECAUSE
EVERYBODY'S REALLY TAKING THIS
VERY SERIOUSLY. BECAUSE WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THE IMPACT THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSE ON THE INDUSTRY
AS A WHOLE ARE AND.
WE WE TALKED ABOUT THERE'S A LOT
OF SUCCESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT ABOUT BECAUSE OF THIS
TAX CREDIT PROGRAM ARE AND THIS
IS ABSOLUTELY SOMETHING THAT FOR
THE STATE.
IS A HUGE NET POSITIVE ARM BUT
WE RECOGNIZE THE WORK AND ADD
THAT WE NEED TO DO AND WE
RECOGNIZE AYE THAT WE'RE ARE
INCLUSIVE STATE. AND WE WANT
EVERY INDUSTRY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO BE ARE JUST AS
INCLUSIVE AS AS WE ARE AND AND
AND REPRESENTATIVE IN THE
POLICIES THAT WE PASS HERE. ARE
IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE ARE AND
WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT YOU KNOW
OUR STATE HAS AN IMPACT.
NOT JUST A ACROSS THIS COUNTRY
BUT ACROSS
IT REALLY AROUND THE WORLD
ESPECIALLY ON THIS INDUSTRY
BECAUSE THIS IS OUR INDUSTRY AND
IF WE DO THE RIGHT THING HERE.
AND WE CAN DO THE RIGHT THING TO
INCLUDE MORE PEOPLE OF COLOR TO
TO MAKE SURE WE'RE WE'RE
INCREASING DIVERSITY CUTTING
DOWN AND OTHER THINGS THAT
SHOULDN'T BE HAPPENING. OUT IN
THIS INDUSTRY THAT'LL HAVE A
RIPPLE EFFECT UP FOR THIS
INDUSTRY NOT JUST IN THE STATE
BUT EVERYWHERE.
AND WE WANNA BE THAT EXAMPLE ARE
YOU KNOW IN WHETHER IT IS WHAT
WHAT WHAT WHAT WE PASSED IS
PICKED UP BY OTHER.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OR YOU KNOW
STATE GOVERNMENTS ARE INCLUDED
AND POLICY BECAUSE THAT'S THE
CHANGE THAT THEY MADE OR JUST AN
INDUSTRY ADOPTED. OP PROGRAMS
THAT THEY JUST CHOOSE TO ADOPT
ON THEIR OWN BECAUSE THEY KNOW
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO WE
HEAR CAN SET THAT TONE IN
CALIFORNIA AND IT'S ON ALL OF US
TO MAKE SURE WE'RE WORKING
TOWARDS THOSE GOALS. ARE BUT I
REALLY BELIEVE IN THIS INDUSTRY
I REALLY LOVED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN'S COMMENTS ABOUT
TOURISM AND THE IMPACT THAT THE
ECONOMIC IMPACT THAT THIS
INDUSTRY HAS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WE ALSO LOVE TO
BE ABLE TO KEEP OUR FAMILY
TOGETHER BECAUSE THAT SHOULD BE
IMPORTANT EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US
AND WE ARE ALL AFFECTED BY THAT.
TO REALLY THINK EVERYBODY FOR
THE TIME I REALLY THINK THE
COALITION A REALLY THINK OUR
JOINT AUTHORS ARE WITNESSES I'M
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
AND WITH
.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN THIRTY
FOUR.
DO YOU PASS.
SOME ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN
THIRTY FOUR CALDERON TO PASS TO
COMMITTEE ON REVENUE AND
TAXATION.
KANSEN CHU RGHT KANSEN CHU AYE
WALDRON WALDRON AYE ACOSTA BY A
CONSTANT ON ME DAVID CHIU BY.
DAVID CHIU AYE FRIEDMAN.
MEDINA.
NAZARIAN BY.
MS ARYAN I.
DO YOU PASS CLINTON COVER MUCH
OF NO POTS WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR
THE APPS AND.
A MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MEMBER MUCH.
MEMBER CHOL HERE.
NO.
MEMBERS GLORIA.
YOUR OWN
.
SOON.
OUR I MEMBERS GLORIA YOUR OWN
WITH GRAVY TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY
SIX
SIR GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I
BRING BEFORE YOU TODAY A BILL
THAT IS NEAR AND DEAR TO MY
HEART AS THE LEGISLATURE'S ONLY
ENROLLED TRIBAL MEMBER. AB
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY SIX SEEKS TO
FINALLY PUT AN END TO A DECADES
OLD CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
DISPOSITION OF NATIVE AMERICAN
REMAINS AND ARTIFACTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY HELD AT VARIOUS
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CAMPUSES.
AS YOUR STAFF AXLE ANNOUNCES
POINTS OUT AB TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY SIX REQUIRE THE UC
REGENTS TO ESTABLISH AND SUPPORT
A SYSTEM WIDE COMMITTEE. AND THE
CAMPUS SPECIFIC IN A CAMPUS
SPECIFIC COMMITTEES TO ESTABLISH
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES FOR THE
APPROPRIATE TREATMENT OF NATIVE
AMERICAN HUMAN REMAINS AND
CULTURAL ITEMS IN THE POSSESSION
OF YOU SEE CAMPUSES. AND
MUSEUMS.
AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY SIX COMES
AFTER DECADES OF LEGISLATION
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS AND THREATS
OF LITIGATION FROM NUMEROUS
SOVEREIGN TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS.
FOLLOWING THE NACHMAN OF THE
FEDERAL NATIVE AMERICAN GRAVES
PROTECTION AND REPATRIATION ACT
IN NINETEEN NINETY. THIS
LEGISLATURE OVERWHELMINGLY
PASSED A BEAT NINE SEVENTY EIGHT
BY THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALE
STEINBERG TO ENSURE PROPER
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS NEW
FEDERAL LAW.
REGRETTABLY SEVERAL UC CAMPUSES
HAVE NOT ONLY FAILED TO
IMPLEMENT THE LAW AS INTENDED.
BUT SEVERAL OF OUR TRIBAL
PARTNERS REPORT THE UC SYSTEM
HAS FAILED TO ADEQUATELY INVOLVE
TRAVEL STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THESE IMPORTANT
PROCESS HE'S.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE HELD AN OVERSIGHT
HEARING TO EXAMINE THIS ISSUE.
AND WHILE MOST OF US WERE NOT IN
THE LEGISLATURE AT THAT TIME
ACCORDING TO THE TRANSCRIPT IT
IS CLEAR THAT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WERE FRUSTRATED BY THE
UC'S LACK OF PROGRESS. AND
REPATRIATING BEATS HUMAN REMAINS
AND OTHER IMPORTANT ARTIFACTS.
HEARING RESULTED IN SEVERAL
RECOMMENDATIONS WHICH CAN BE
FOUND ON PAGE ELEVEN OF YOUR
ANALYSIS.
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDE
CAMPUS LEVEL COLLABORATION WITH
TRIBES AND CAMPUS LEVEL CLASS OF
COMPLIANCE COMMITTEES.
WHICH ARE COOPERATED INTO THIS
BILL BEFORE YOU THIS MORNING.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT MANY OF
THESE REMAINS AND ARTIFACTS ARE
HOUSED IN STORAGE UNITS AND
OTHER FACILITIES THAT DO NOT
RESPECT THE SACRED NATURE OF
THESE ITEMS.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW NATIVE
AMERICANS BELIEVE THAT THEIR
ANCESTORS CANNOT REST IN THE TO
TELL THE REMAINS ARE PROPERLY
CARED FOR MAKING THIS BILL
DEEPLY PERSONAL TO ALL INVOLVED.
I'M ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT THIS
MORNING FOR AB TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY SIX TO HOPEFULLY ONCE AND
FOR ALL CONCLUDE A CONVERSATION
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE'S BEEN
HAVING WITH UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA FOR DECADES.
I'VE ASKED TO MEET WITH
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE UC.
TO HEAR SOME OF THEIR FOR THE
FROM BE TO HEAR THEIR
PERSPECTIVE AND TO TOUR SOME OF
THEIR FACILITIES WHERE THESE
ARTIFACTS AND REMAINS ARE BEING
HELD.
MY WE HAVE NOT HEARD BACK ON
THAT REQUEST MY INTENTION IS TO
FIND COMMON GROUND IF POSSIBLE
IN ORDER TO REAP REPATRIATE.
THESE ARTIFACTS REMAINS.
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THIS
MORNING WITH APPRECIATION FOR
THIS COMMITTEES VALUABLE TIME
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE BY REMISE
OUT ZAMORA.
MYERS A PECHANGA MEMBER AND A
CAL GRAD WHO IS AN INTERNET THE
PHOEBE HEARST MUSEUM WHILE AT
CAO. AND SHE'S CURRENTLY PART OF
THE CHILD THE TRIBAL CULTURAL
DEPARTMENT AND IS IT'S EXPERT IN
TRIBAL HISTORY AND CULTURE.
SEE ALSO JOINED TODAY BY POLITY
THEIR REPRESENTATIVE AND THE
AUDIENCE HAVE JACOB HERE WHO IS
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF TOSS
IN THE TRIBAL ALLIANCE OF
SOVEREIGN INDIAN NATIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
MUSEUM. HELLO EVERYONE GOOD
MORNING.
MY NAME IS MEYER MONTHS SALES
AMORA AND I EARNED A BA IN
ANTHROPOLOGY FROM UC BERKELEY.
AND TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN IRON MY
MASTER'S DEGREE IN ANTHROPOLOGY
WITH THE FOCUS IN ARCHAEOLOGY
FROM SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY.
AND BECAME A REGISTERED
ARCHAEOLOGISTS WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I AM ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
PECHANGA BAND OF THE SEND YOU
INDIANS Y. SERVICE THE TRIBAL
ARCHAEOLOGIST AND CURATOR.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. WE ARE HERE TODAY
TO ASK FOR YOUR HELP IN
RETURNING OUR GREAT GREAT
GRANDPARENTS AND THEIR FUNERARY
ITEMS HOME.
TO WHERE THEY BELONG SO WE CAN
GIVE THEM A PROPER BURIAL WITH
THE RESPECT AND DIGNITY. THAT
THEY AND ALL OTHER PEOPLE
DESERVES.
ALMOST THIRTY YEARS HAVE PASSED
SINCE THE ENACTMENT OF THE
FEDERAL NATIVE AMERICAN GRAVES
PROTECTION AND REPATRIATION ACT
NAGRA.
THAT REQUIRES FEDERALLY FUNDED
MUSEUMS AND UNIVERSITIES TO
REPATRIATE HUMAN REMAINS AND IS
SO SHE DID. AN UNASSOCIATED
FUNERARY OBJECTS
TO FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES.
SINCE ITS PASSAGE MANY FEDERAL
AGENCIES AND MUSEUMS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY HAVE REPATRIATED. NATIVE
AMERICAN REMAINS AND THEIR
POSSESSIONS BUT THERE IS STILL
MORE WORK TO
BE DONE. TO SAFELY RETURN ALL OF
OUR ANCESTORS AND THEIR
BELONGINGS HEARING CALIFORNIA.
IN OUR HOME STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CURRENT LAW HAS PROVEN TO BE AN
ADEQUATE. AND INEFFECTIVE
WHEN IT COMES TO RESEARCH
UNIVERSITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
MY ANCESTORS
ARE STILL SEEN AS SPECIMENS
TO MANY RESEARCHERS INSTEAD OF
HUMAN BEINGS.
WHAT THE RIGHT TO A FINAL
RESTING PLACE?
IN FACT
AS OF JUNE TO THOUSAND THIRTEEN.
UC BERKELEY HAD REPATRIATED ONLY
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN.
OF ITS TEN THOUSAND REMAINS.
THE UNIVERSITY HAS FOUND WAYS
UNDER THE CURRENT NAG PRO LAW TO
STALL THE REPATRIATION PROCESS
AND IN MANY CASES.
OUTRIGHT DENIED CLAIMS AND
REQUESTS FOR REPATRIATION.
THE DENIAL OF THE RETURN OF MY
GREAT GREAT GREAT GRANDMOTHER
AND THOSE OF OTHER CALIFORNIA
TRIBES.
HUGHES HUMAN BONES WERE DUG UP
IN THE NAME OF SCIENCE
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS ANY MORAL. AND
FRANKLY A VIOLATION. OF BASIC
HUMAN RIGHTS FOR INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE.
THIS IS NOT ONLY A PERSONAL
MATTER FOR ME AS WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT MY ANCESTORS HUMAN
REMAINS.
BUT I WAS AN UNDERGRADUATE IN
TURN AT THE PHOEBE HEARST MUSEUM
OF ANTHROPOLOGY ON THE UC
BERKELEY CAMPUS.
AND TWO THOUSAND THREE I WAS AN
INTERN IN THE KNACK FOR DIVISION
AT PHOEBE HEARST
ASSISTING WITH NAG PRO
REPATRIATIONS.
FOR CALIFORNIA TRIBES.
I WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR CHECKING
INVENTORY FOR NAGRA COLLECTIONS.
AND DURING CONSULTATION IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE. WITH A NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA TRIBE.
THE PHOEBE HEARST NAG PER
DIRECTOR AT THE TIME BROUGHT OUT
A CARD OF A SO SHE DID FUNERARY
OBJECTS.
THAT THE TRIBE WAS REQUESTING TO
REPATRIATE.
DURING THE CONSULTATION.
TRIBAL ELDERS TOLD THE NAGRA
DIRECTOR THAT THEY THOUGHT THEY
WERE ADDITIONAL ITEMS THAT WERE
INCLUDED IN THEIR CURRENT
REPATRIATION CLAIM.
BUT THE DIRECTOR DENIED THAT ANY
ADDITIONAL ITEMS WERE IN THE
MUSEUM'S POSSESSION.
BECAUSE I HAD CHECKED THE
INVENTORIES OF ALL THAT PER
ITEMS.
I NEW PERSONALLY THAT THEY WERE
ADDITIONAL FUNERARY OBJECTS FOR
THE MUSEUM WAS FAILING TO DENY.
AS THEY LOOKED AT THESE ELDERS
SITTING AROUND THE TABLE SEEING
THEIR SAD FACES AND TEARS ROLLED
DOWN HER CHEEKS.
I WAS DISGUSTED.
YOU KNOW AS WELL AS ME.
THAT THIS IS NOT A UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCE.
THIS BILL WILL COMPEL
INSTITUTIONS TO TAKE
CONSULTATION AND OUTREACH TO
TRIBES MORE SERIOUSLY.
IN ORDER TO RETURN HUMAN
REMAINS.
AND THOSE PEOPLE'S PERSONAL
POSSESSIONS
OFF THE MUSEUM SHELVES AND
DRAWERS AND RETURN THEM HOME TO
THE APPROPRIATE TRIBE FOR PROPER
CARE.
IT MANDATES A TRANSPARENT
PROCESS
FOR THE RETURN OF OUR ANCESTORS
AND THE ITEMS THEY WERE BURIED
WITH.
THE BILL REQUIRES ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR THE UC SYSTEM. TO HELP
ENSURE THAT REPATRIATION CLAIMS.
OUR PROCESS FAIRLY AND TIMELY.
THE BILL CREATES A CHECKS AND
BALANCE SYSTEM BY REQUIRING THAT
NAG PROPOSE SEES.
AND THEIR PROCEDURES
INCLUDE TRIBAL VOICE.
BOTH IN THE CREATION OF THEM AND
IN THEIR IMPLEMENTATION.
FURTHER ACCOUNTABILITY.
IS REQUIRED THROUGH AN AUDIT
EVERY TWO YEARS FOR NAG PRO
COMPLIANCE IN THE UC SYSTEM.
IN RECENT DECADES CALIFORNIA HAS
MADE GREAT PROGRESS TREATING
INDIAN TRIBES WITH RESPECT AND
DIGNITY.
WHAT IS HAPPENING UNDER NAGRA IS
NOT CONSISTENT WITH THE VALUES
THAT WE HAVE HEARD EXPRESSED AT
MEMORIALIZED?
IN OTHER STATE POLICIES.
SO WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY SIX.
ON BEHALF
OF THOUSANDS OF NATIVE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN REMOVED
FROM THEIR FINAL RESTING PLACE.
IN MANY CASES DUG UP OVER A
CENTURY AGO AND SUBJECT TO
DESECRATION.
IN CLOSING.
I SPEAK TO ALL THE NATIVE
AMERICAN HUMAN BONES AND
SPIRITS.
BETTER STILL IN THE MUSEUM
HOLDINGS
THAT WE WILL NEVER FORGET YOU.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR
YOUR RETURN.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PAULA.
MISTER CHAIR.
AND VICE CHAIR UPPALA TREAT ON
BEHALF OF THE JUNGLE BAND
LOOSING YOU INDIANS AND THE.
COLUSA INDIAN COMMUNITY OUT ONE
THINKING OF THE AUTHOR VERY MUCH
IN THE CO AUTHORS FOR FOR
BRINGING THIS I WAS HERE TWENTY
YEARS AGO WHEN THIS CAME UP IN
HEARING I WAS HERE TEN YEARS AGO
WHEN THIS CAME UP IN HEARINGS.
AND NOTHING HAS HAPPENED I'M
EMBARRASSED TO SAY THAT I'M A
CAL GRAD AND AS YOU HEARD FROM
MYRA THAT'S THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN REMAINS OUT OF TEN
THOUSAND. HAVE BEEN REPATRIATED.
SO THIS HAS TO STOP I DON'T KNOW
HOW WE DO IT ABOVE AND BEYOND
THIS BILL MAYBE YOU EVEN LOOK AT
THEIR BUDGETS BUT I WILL TELL
YOU THAT IT'S A A VERY UPSETTING
TO ME IT SHOULD BE FOR EVERYBODY
IN THIS ENTIRE BODY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYA
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
OF AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY SIX.
PLEASE COME FORWARD STATE YOUR
NAME. AND YOUR AFFILIATION.
YES BILL ARE NOT TAKING TIME TO
HEAR FOR THE BROWN A BAND OF
MISSION INDIANS ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
AFTER REGARD FOR THE RINCON BAND
OF RELEASING YOU INDIANS
THANK YOU.
DRIVEN SENATOR BEHALF OF ANY
OTHER AUBURN INDIAN COMMUNITY WE
THINK THE AUTHOR.
SPONSORS
STRONG SPRINGS BILL.
EDU.
MICHAEL I DON'T HAVE A TABLE
MOUNT RANCHERIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SCOTT GOVERNOR BEHALF MORONGO
BAND OF MISSION INDIANS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT XENON.
INDIA OPPOSITION.
SCOPE OVER.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SUCH A SUMMER FIAT
BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA WE ARE NOT IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THIS
TIME.
HOWEVER WE DID WANT TO COME
FORWARD TODAY AND AND TO SHARE A
LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND AND.
VIEWPOINT FROM REVERSE EFFECT
TO ON OUR PRIOR ART PREVIOUSLY
TO THIS BILL ONE OF LET THE
MEMBER KNOW WE WILL BE BACK IN
TOUCH WITH YOU VERY SHORTLY. TO
FOLLOW UP ON YOUR REQUEST TO
MEET AND PERHAPS A PRODUCTIVE IS
LOOKING FOR IS A CALIFORNIA AND
I WANT TO SAY. GENERALLY THAT IT
IS SOME.
MY VIEW THE UNIVERSITY HAS.
SOUGHT TO TAKE A VERY.
DIGNIFIED AND RESPECTFUL.
APPROACH WITH RESPECT TO ALL
THESE VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES I'VE
A COLLEAGUE WITH BEING A
MEDICINA MOM TO COULD SPEAK TO
MORE THE DETAILS.
.
BUT ONE DOES THAT KNOWLEDGE THAT
THAT WE WE DO BELIEVE THAT WE'VE
ACTED IN GOOD FAITH. WITH REGARD
TO THE PROCESSES THAT WE MUST
FOLLOW UNDERSTAND FEDERAL LAW.
AND THAT.
WE'RE CONTINUE TO MOVE
EXPEDITIOUSLY THROUGH THOSE
THOSE IMPORTANT PROCESS THESE.
BEFORE I TURNED OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE IS ONE MOMENT LIKE TO
SAY THAT.
WE THINK THAT THERE MAY BE SOME
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AS
RESULT THIS BILL ONE BILL TALK
THROUGH THOSE LOVE IT WITH YOU
AND AND THE AUTHOR. I AND ALSO
JUST AS WELL NOTE THAT THEM WE
WANT ALSO EXPLORE SOME OF THE
POTENTIAL. ISSUES THAT MAY COME
UP THE GUARD TO UNIVERSITIES
CONSTITUTIONAL ECONOMY WITH
RESPECT TO THIS ISSUE AS WELL
SO.
WITHOUT A LIKE TO HAND OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUE A ONE STRIKE
FLINTRIDGE RESOURCE.
MORNING.
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
RESEARCH POLICY AT THE OFFICE OF
PRESIDENT.
IN THAT CAPACITY WE WE ARE MORE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
UNIVERSITY'S RESEARCH POLICIES
INCLUDING THE ONES RELATED TO
THAT PRO.
WE CONVENE THE SYSTEM WIDE NET
FOR ADVISORY GROUP WE PROVIDE
GUIDANCE TO CAMPUSES AND WE
INVITE WE REVISE POLICIES AT AS
NECESSARY.
ONE OF MY STAFF MEMBERS RETIRED
LAST YEAR AND HE HAD THE DEEP
EXPERTISE IN THIS AREA.
I'M COMING UP TO SPEED AS
QUICKLY AS I CAN. ABA WE'RE IN
THE PROCESS OF CONVENING ARE
ADVISORY GROUP RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE GOING TO BE REVIEWING
OUR EXISTING POLICY WHICH I
DON'T UNDERSTAND ALREADY NEED
SOME REVISION. SO.
AS WITH OTHER AREAS OF RESEARCH
RELATED POLICY I'M COMMITTED TO
ENSURING A THOUGHTFUL AND
BALANCED APPROACH IS TAKEN FOR
THESE EFFORTS.
ALL OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IS FULLY COMMITTED TO
THE REPATRIATION OF NATIVE
AMERICAN HUMAN REMAINS AND
ASSOCIATED OBJECTS. AT AS
REQUIRED BY FEDERAL AND STATE
LAW.
OUR MISSION OF COURSES TEACHING
RESEARCH AND PUBLIC SERVICE WE
AIM TO SERVE SOCIETY IS THE
CENTER OF HIGHER LEARNING
PROVIDE LONG TERM SOCIETAL
BENEFITS TO TRANSMIT ADVANCE
KNOWLEDGE DISCOVERING NEW
KNOWLEDGE AND FUNCTIONING AS AN
ACTIVE WORKING REPOSITORY. OF
ORGANIZE KNOWLEDGE.
SIX OF OUR CAMPUSES HOUSE
RESEARCH COLLECTIONS THAT
INCLUDE NATIVE AMERICAN CULTURAL
OBJECTS IN REMAINS.
THE UNIVERSITY FULLY
ACKNOWLEDGES THE DIFFICULT AND
FRAUGHT CONTEXT IN WHICH MANY OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS OBJECTS WERE
MOVED FROM THEIR BURIAL
LOCATIONS ARE COMMUNITIES PRIOR
TO. THE CURRENT CULTURAL
RESOURCES PROTECTIONS AND OFTEN
WITHOUT CONSENT FROM THE
DESCENDANT COMMUNITIES.
UP FEDERAL MAG PARA WAS ENACTED
SO JUST A LITTLE BIT OF A BREAK
BACKGROUND FEDERAL MAG PER WAS
ENACTED IN NINETEEN NINETY TO
SHELVE THE SYSTEMATIC PROCESS
FOR DETERMINING RIGHTS OF LINEAL
DESCENDANTS.
TO CERTAIN HUMAN REIGNS AND AND
ASSOCIATED OBJECTS WITH WHICH
THEY'RE AFFILIATED IT'S A HIGHLY
COMPLEX
LAW AIMED AT ESTABLISHING
REPATRIATION RIGHTS FOR TRIBES.
AND WAS NEGOTIATED THE BALANCE
BETWEEN NATIVE AMERICAN
SCIENTIFIC AND MUSEUM
COMMUNITIES.
FOR YOU SEE THE STUDY AND
PRESERVATION OF CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN HISTORIES
LANGUAGES AND MATERIAL CULTURE
HAVE LONG BEEN SOURCES OF DEEP
INTEREST.
OR UNIVERSITY ANTHROPOLOGIST
HISTORIC AND HISTORIANS AND
LINGUISTS.
HUMAN REMAINS AND ASSOCIATED
MATERIALS HAVE COME TO OUR
CAMPUSES FROM OF ROT WIDE
VARIETY OF MEANS INCLUDING
UNINTENTIONAL DISCOVERIES.
TRANSFERS FROM COUNTY CORONER
OFFICE AT CORNERS OFFICES.
AND EVEN DONATIONS TO HELP TO
UNDERSTAND THE BROADER STORY OF
HUMANITY SUCH AS HOW TO BECOME
TO OCCUPY THE PLANET AND MIGRATE
THE WORLD.
EXISTING CALIFORNIA POLICY
POLICY AND PROCEDURES ON
CURATION REPATRIATION OF HUMAN
REMAINS AND CULTURAL ITEMS IS
ADOPTED IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE
LATIN LAST SUBSTANCE WE REVISED
IN TWO THOUSAND ONE. TO REQUIRE
COMPLIANCE WITH NIAGARA
INCLUDING RICK REQUIRING
REPATRIATION OF NATIVE AMERICAN
RATE REMAINS AN ASSOCIATE OF
OBJECTS.
WE FIND THAT MUCH OF AB TWENTY
THIRTY SIX IS REDUNDANT WITH THE
UNIVERSITY'S CURRENT POLICY AND
PRACTICES. AS SUCH WE BELIEVE
IT'S IT'S UNNECESSARY OVERLY
PRESCRIPTIVE ADDING A LAYER OF
BUREAUCRACY. THAT MAY LIMIT THE
RANGE OF EXPERTISE THE
UNIVERSITY CAN DRAWN IN ITS
IMPLEMENTATION COMPLIANCE
EFFORTS COMPLICATE THE INTERNAL
REVIEW PROCESS. AND THEREBY HAVE
THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF
ACTUALLY DELAYING RESPONSES TO
REPATRIATION REQUESTS. THE RIGID
ADMINISTRATIVE MEASURES DO NOT
ACCOUNT FOR VARIABILITY IN
CAMPUS COLLECTIONS OR BETWEEN
AND AMONG NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES.
MOREOVER FROM THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS IT SEEMS AT THIS MAY BE
DRIVEN. BY VERY OUTDATED
PERCEPTION ABOUT A PARTICULAR
INCIDENT EVEN AT THE TIME THE
CAMPUS INVOLVED FELT THAT THERE
ARE SIGNIFICANT MISS
CHARACTERIZATIONS BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY IT FAILS TO
RECOGNIZE. THAT OUR CAMPUSES ARE
CONSTANTLY SEEKING TO IMPROVE
THEIR PROCESSES TO IMPROVE THEIR
RELATIONS.
FOR EXAMPLE UC DAVIS LAST YEAR
REINVENTED AND REINVIGORATED AND
DIVERSE SYFY THEIR LOCAL CAMPUS
COMMITTEE. THEY CONSULTED WITH
TRIBES IN THE CREATION OF A NEW
POLICIES THAT'S NOW IN EFFECT.
A SIMILARLY AFTER TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN REVIEW BERKELEY IS
MAKING MAJOR CHANGES TO ITS
COMMITTEE MEMBERSHIP AND AND.
THE TERMS OF ITS MEMBERS.
UNDER THE UC POLICY MOST OF THE
DAY IMPLEMENTATION ACTIVITIES.
SKY SIR I'M GETTING INTO THE
POLICY ITSELF A LITTLE BIT NOT
JUST TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF WHAT
THE POLICY DOES TO.
MOST OF THE DAY TO DAY
IMPLEMENTATION ACTIVITIES OCCUR
AT THE CAMPUS LEVEL BUT THE
POLICY ALSO REQUIRES SYSTEM WIDE
LEVEL REVIEW AND APPROVAL OF
CAMPUS IS PROPOSED CULTURAL
AFFILIATIONS AND REPATRIATIONS.
AND ESTABLISHES A SYSTEM WIDE
ADVISORY GROUP TO REVIEW AND
ADVISE THE PRESIDENT ON THESE
MATTERS.
THE POLICY REQUIRES CAMPUSES TO
PREPARE INVENTORIES AND
SUMMARIES OF THEIR COLLECTION IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE TRIBES
WHICH THEY HAVE DONE.
I WANTED TO SHARE A COUPLE
NUMBERS WITH YOU.
.
IN A RECENT CHECK WE'VE.
PUBLISHED ON SIX THOUSAND EIGHT
AMERICAN HUMAN REMAINS AND OVER
TO WORK TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
ASSOCIATED FUNERAL OBJECTS
SYSTEM WIDE. MANY OF THESE
REMAINS HAVE BEEN CLAIMED AND
TRANSFER TO MAKE NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES FOR BURIAL BUT THE
MAJORITY HAVE NOT YET BEEN
CLAIMED. ARE AND CONTINUE TO BE
HOUSE UC CAMPUSES UNTIL SUCH
REQUESTS FOR REPATRIATION ARE
MADE.
FOR EXAMPLE UC BERKELEY A FULL
EIGHTY TWO PERCENT OF THE HUMAN
REMAINS PUBLISHED AS CULTURALLY
AFFILIATED REMAIN THE HEARST
MUSEUMS CARE TO BE TRANSFERRED
AT THE AFFILIATE THE TRIBES
DISCRETION. AT SUCH TIME AS
THEIR OWN CULTURAL SPIRITUAL AND
LOGISTICS ALLOW.
.
TROUBLE IS IT AGAIN GOING BACK
TO THE POLICY.
TRIBAL AUTHORITIES ARE TO BE
PERMITTED REASONABLE ACCESS TO
EXAMINE ITEMS IN ORDER TWO
EVALUATE THE CULTURAL
AFFILIATION. THERE ALSO TO BE
GIVEN REASONABLE OPPORTUNITY
UPON REQUEST TO RESENT THEIR
VIEWS ORALLY OR IN WRITING TO
CAMPUS OFFICIALS.
THE PERSPECTIVES OF SUCH TRIBAL
AUTHORITIES MUST BE CONSIDERED
IN DETERMINING CULTURAL
AFFILIATION.
ARE YOU SEE POLICY REQUIRES EACH
CAMPUS WITH A COVERED COLLECTION
TO HAVE A LIAISON.
TO CULTIVATE A POSITIVE RELATION
SHIP WITH NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES TO MAKE UNIVERSITY
COLLECTIONS OF NATIVE REMAINS
AND ITEMS ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
TRIBES. AND TO ASSIST TRIBES IN
UNDERSTANDING AND INVOKING THE
REPATRIATION PROCESS
THE LIAISON.
AS ASSIST TRIBES IN PLANNING
FOR REPATRIATION OF CULTURAL
AFFILIATED ITEMS AND FACILITATES
EXAMINATION OF CULTURALLY
IDENTIFIABLE ITEMS BUT TROUBLE
AUTHORITIES AND I WILL SAY. TO
OF OUR CAMPUSESHAVE ACTUALLY
HELPED THE TRIBES FIND LEON FOR
THE REPATRIATION ON ON PROPERTY
OWNED BY THE CAMPUSES.
I WANTED TO POINT OUT JUST A
COUPLE OF.
MISCONCEPTIONS THAT SEEM TO BE
IN AB TWENTY THIRTY SIX ONE IS
THAT THERE'S A HIS.
OKAY THE HISTORY OF RESISTANCE
TO COMPLY WITH REPATRIATION.
WEEK KNOWLEDGE THAT THE TRIBES
MAY DISAGREE WITH SOME OF OUR
DETERMINATIONS HOWEVER IT CAMPUS
IS COMMITTED THE FACT THAT THE
TRIBE MAY DISAGREE WITH THE
DETERMINATION DOES NOT MEAN THAT
THE CAMPUS IS RESISTANT TO
COMPLYING WITH LEGAL MANDATES.
.
THE ANOTHER REALLY IMPORTANT
WHEN I WANTED TO SAY IS THAT.
THAT THERE'S VERY PRESCRIPTIVE
IN TERMS OF COMMITTEE MEMBERSHIP
ALLEN AND THINGS.
.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S BEEN
SOME FRUSTRATION CAUSED BY
OPPOSING VIEWS BUT WE BELIEVE
THE OPPOSING VIEWS SHOULD NOT BE
LEGISLATIVELY SILENCED.
SO OFTEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL OF POSITIONS PLEASE
COME FOR. IT DAVID KEENE TANA
WITH THE HOUSE BAND OF CAHUILLA
INDIANS HAVE POLITICS I AM NOT
IN OPPOSITION. BUT I MISS THE
SUPPORT IN AND IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT FOR IT TO BE A HUSBAND
COULD BE AYE AND INSTEAD MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE ON THE RECORD.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THINK WE'LL MAKE SURE YOU PUT ON
THE RECORD THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY QUESTIONS.
BUT IF YOU A QUESTION TO YOU SEE
IS A REASON WHY YOU HAVE NOT SAT
DOWN YET WITH THE AUTHOR. WITH
THE TRIBES DISCUSSES THIS YEAR
WITH THE BILL BEING INTRODUCED.
I THINK IT'S JUST A MATTER OF OF
TIME AND RESOURCES MY COLLEAGUES
ARE IN OAKLAND AND.
WEIRD JUST UNABLE TO GET
OURSELVES ORGANIZED PRIOR TO THE
HEARING TODAY TO HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED ADMITTING YET BUT
WILL. CERTAINLY DO SO VERY
SHORTLY AFTER THE SAGA.
IT'S A PERFECT DAY.
OKAY I IAN OFFICE OF THIS BILL
IS THE SPELLS BEEN AROUND AND
INTRODUCE EARLY THIS YEAR EH
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE I.
READY NOW SUCCESS NIGHT IT WAS
REALLY MY FIRST INTRODUCTION TO
THE ISSUE AND AND AND FRANKLY IS
IS VERY SURPRISING WHAT WHAT I
THINK. WE ALL KNOW AND LEARN AND
I KNOW NOW THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
SPAN. OUTSTANDING FOR A COUPLE
OF DECADES.
AND.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IT NEEDS TO
BE RESOLVED AND AND FRANKLY IT
IT IT STRIKES I THINK MANY OF US
THAT.
THE FACT THAT YOU SEE IS NOT
APPROACH THE AUTHOR DISCUSSES
AND WE'RE ALL HEARING ABOUT THIS
TODAY. AYE AS A CONTINUATION OF
OF WHERE YOU SEE HAS BEEN ON
THIS ISSUE SO. I'M A VERY MUCH
DO HOPE THAT YOU CAN ENGAGE WELL
WITH THE AUTHOR.
I CERTAINLY PLAN TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL ARE I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO TO MAKE A MOTION MOVE IT
FORWARD AND. AND.
IF IT MAKES SENSE TO THE OFTEN
THE SPONSORS HAPPY TO AT MYSELF
AS A CO AUTHOR OF THE BILL.
YOU DO HAVE A MOTION WILL HAVE
THE SECOND.
MEMBER KNOWS EVERY.
THANK YOU AND AND I.
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO ECHO THE
SENTIMENTS OF WHAT MY COLLEAGUE
SAID A AYE PERCIVAL WOULD LOVE
TO BE A CO AUTHOR JUST TO SHOW
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR.
.
HEARTFELT AND AMAZING
PRESENTATION.
.
SO IF YOU HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE
ORDER HAVING HAD THE RESOURCES
TO SPEAK WITH THE AUTHOR.
IN THE LAST THREE MONTHS WHY
HASN'T IT TAKE WHY HAS IT TAKEN
TWENTY YEARS.
TO GET TO A POINT TO TRY TO FIND
RESOLUTION TO THIS ISSUE.
LEGISLATIVELY.
THAT DETERIORATES CONFIDENCE.
WHAT WHAT RESPONSE THE AFTER
THAT?
WELL I WOULD SUGGEST THAT WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING I THINK MY
COLLEAGUE WAS JUST SPEAKING TO
THE.
LENGTHY AN EXTENSIVE
ACTIVITIES ARE UNDERTAKEN AS A
RESULT OF STATE AND FEDERAL LAW
IN THIS AREA BUT IT'S ONE THING
TO COMPLY TO FEDERAL MANDATES.
IF IT'S NOT RESPECTFUL OR TAKING
INTO CONSIDERATION OUR ACCOUNT.
WHAT THE TRIBES THEMSELVES ARE
TRAINED ADVANCE?
SO WHAT IT IT SEEMS LIKE THERE'S
JUST BEEN AN ABSENCE OF.
CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS BEING AT THE
TABLE.
AND HAVING THE APPROPRIATE
DIALOGUE WITH YOU SO THAT.
IT WOULDN'T OF REACH TO THIS
POINT.
SO WHAT I CAN SAY THAT IS A
AGAIN I'M I'M NEW TO THIS FIELD
AND TRYING TO COME UP TO SPEED
ON THAT HARD BUT I CAMPUS I'M
SORRY THAT DOESN'T COVER IT. BUT
OUR CAMPUS ENGLISH POWERFUL OUR
CAMPUSES HAVE BEEN WORKING TO
IMPROVE THE PROCESSES LIKE I
SAID OF THE COUPLE OF CAMPUSES
THAT HAVE HAD.
THE MOST DISPUTES HAVE
COMPLETELY OVERHAULED IN THE
LAST YEAR THEIR PROPHECIES IN
THE COMMITTEES BEING AND AND OUR
OFFICE REQUIRES THEM.
TO CONSULT WITH AND TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE VIEWS AND CONCERNS
OF THE TRIBES.
SO I ASK AGAIN. TAKEN TWENTY
YEARS TO GET TO THIS POINT.
I GUESS WHAT I'M SAYING IS THERE
HAS BEEN SIGNIFICANT CHANGE THAT
THIS LEGISLATION DOESN'T TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT.
OKAY WELL.
WE ALL TO OFTEN.
WHETHER IN THIS COMMITTEE OR THE
COMMITTEES
SEE THE INSTITUTIONAL BIASES
UNFORTUNATELY. BECAUSE OF HOUSE
CERTAIN LAWS.
ARE WRITTEN.
WHAT DID OF OUR HOMES SAY?
?
SO THERE'S A LOT OF
INSTITUTIONAL BIAS EMBEDDED
WHERE YOUNG STATE.
OR A YOUNG COUNTRY COMPARATIVELY
SPEAKING.
SO IT'S.
I WOULD URGE YOU.
TOOK TO TO COME UP TO SOME FORM
OF RESOLUTION WITH THE BY IT
WITH THE AUTHOR. AND THOSE THAT
HE REPRESENTS AND SPEAKING FOR.
BECAUSE A.
I'D HATE TO SEE FOR THIS ISSUE
TO COME BACK AGAIN IN THE COMING
YEARS IN ANOTHER FORM OF A PILL.
I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU AND
WE CERTAINLY WELCOME
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
BECAUSE WE DO THINK A LOT OF THE
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN OR ARE BEING
ADDRESSED.
I'LL LEAVE IT TO HER.
HOW HOW THIS BILL ADVANCERS?
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAU MEMBERS
ACOSTA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
I AND I. THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR
FOR FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
READING MEDIA THE BILL ANALYSIS
AS WELL.
.
I WOULD LOVE TO SHOW MY SUPPORT
BY JOINING IS A CO AUTHOR AS
WELL.
AND WHAT'S PARTICULARLY
TROUBLING TO TO ME IS THAT.
YOU KNOW SOMEONE LIKE MANY WITH
A NATIVE AMERICAN A LINEAGE.
.
YOU KNOW I MENTIONED IT PRIOR MY
FATHER WAS AN ACTOR AND HE HE
OFTEN PLAYED A NATIVE AMERICAN
ROLES SOME OF THEM ARE NOT IN
THE BEST LIGHT.
BUT THAT'S ENTERTAINMENT IN
HOLLYWOOD IN THE PARTICULARLY IN
THE PAST.
BUT IT WAS ALWAYS A POINT OF
PRIDE FOR HIM I KNOW.
AND.
I JUST LIKE I I CAN'T IMAGINE.
.
YEAH.
THINKING ABOUT HOW. A LOVED ONE
OR LOVED ONES NO MATTER HOW
DISTANT YOU KNOW MINE MANY OF
MINOR BURIED IN.
CEMETERIES RIGHT CAN VISIT.
AND PAY MY RESPECTS INCLUDING
OUR SON.
WE WANTED THEM CLOSE WITH IT
WANTING ONE I'M IN ARLINGTON.
BECAUSE IT'S A PLACE HE WE
DON'T BELIEVE HE'S THERE.
BUT.
WE KNOW THAT'S A PLACE WHERE WE
CAN GO AND PAY OUR RESPECTS.
AND I JUST CAN'T IMAGINE IF.
AND IT IS SOME MORE IN THE DEAD
OF NIGHT.
SOME TOOK HIS REMAINS.
AND I CAN'T FATHOM HOW.
QUESTION WAS JUST ASK HOW IT'S
TAKEN TWENTY YEARS.
AND WE'RE SITTING HERE.
AND I DON'T MEAN TO PUT YOU SEE
ON THE SPOT YOU FOLKS ARE DOING
YOUR JOB AND YOUR YOU KNOW YOUR
SET WITH PAPERS AND MARCHING
ORDERS GOING THEREIN.
DEFEND THE POLICY OR COME UP
WITH A REASON.
BUT I CAN'T BELIEVE IT TAKES ALL
LAW.
I GET THE UC SYSTEM TO DO WHAT
IS.
EVIDENCE PLANE IS THE NEW NOSE
ON YOUR FACE.
THE RIGHT THING THE MORAL THING.
AND I WOULD REALLY ENCOURAGE AND
LOVE TO HEAR FROM FROM THE
AUTHOR MY AND MY FRIEND MISTER
GLORIA. IN THE VERY NEAR FUTURE
BACK TO US IN THIS COMMITTEE AND
AND US ON THE FLOOR WHEREVER YOU
HAPPEN TO CATCH US THAT.
YES WHAT YOU SEE WAS IN MY
OFFICE LAST WEEK.
AND MORE WORK IN THE SOUTH.
AND A AN INDIAN LADY I I
APPRECIATE YOU COMING HERE I
KNOW MUST BE
VERY CHALLENGING.
BUT YOU CAN SEE THAT THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF SUPPORT
FOR THIS.
AND.
WILL BE WATCHING THIS.
ISSUE VERY CAREFULLY BECAUSE WE
HAVE OTHER OTHER LOVERS THAT WE
CAN PULL.
AND.
SELECT YOU AND GETTING THIS
DONE.
YOU KNOW MISTER GLORIA THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AND I'M A BIG.
BIG SUPPORT RIGHT NOW THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A MEMBER
FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU.
.
IN ONE OF THEIR GREATEST SHAMES
OF THIS NATION IS WHAT WAS DONE
TO THE NATIVE PEOPLE.
AND WE'RE NEVER GOING TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE UP FOR THAT EVER.
AND BUT IT'S RARE WHEN WE HAVE A
DAY WHERE WE CAN DO A LITTLE
TEENY BIT TO TRY TO HELP TO.
MAKE UP FOR.
THE HORRORS OF THE PAST AND SO I
WOULD BE VERY HONORED IF YOU
WOULD CONSIDER ADDING ME AS A
CALL AUTHOR TO THIS.
AND.
I AM VERY HAPPY TO I THINK THAT
TODAY ALL OF US ARE GONNA FEEL
GOOD AFTER TAKING THIS VOTE.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU. BYE SHARE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
.
KIND OF ONE OF.
STILL A LOT OF THE REMARKS THAT
WERE ALREADY ME.
IN MY DISTRICT I REPRESENT
EIGHT.
EIGHT FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED
TRIBES WHICH IS QUITE A BIT AND
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO HAS MORE.
.
AND. THROUGH MY WORK WITH THE
DIFFERENT TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS
OVER TWENTY YEARS BEING IN
ELECTED OFFICE BOTH LOCALLY AND
NOW IN THE ASSEMBLY.
I'VE COME TO UNDERSTAND. THE
SOVEREIGNTY ISSUE AS WELL AS.
THE SACREDNESS OF TRIBAL CULTURE
THE SACREDNESS OF TRIBAL
RELIGION.
THE SACREDNESS OF THEIR
HERITAGE.
AND THEIR SACRED SITES ON ALL OF
THE ISSUES THAT THE TRIBAL.
GOVERNMENTS HAVE HAD TO.
STRIVE TO PROTECT.
AND STRIVE TO TEACH THEIR
CHILDREN OVER THE COURSE OF
GENERATIONS OF.
WITH A HOME A LOT OF HOME.
A.
ANXIETY AND A LOT OF.
A IMPETUS AGAINST THEM ALL THE
WAY THROUGH SO I'M. WITH THAT I
WAS JUST WONDERING.
WHERE THE REMAIN STORED NOW OR
HOW ARE THEY WAS HOW WERE THEY
STORED?
I CAN I HAVEN'T.
HAVING BEEN NEWS I HAVEN'T SEEN
THE REMAINS MYSELF I KNOW THE
SIX CAMPUSES HAVE THEM I KNOW
THE BERKELEY HAS THE LARGEST
COLLECTION AMONG THE UC SYSTEM.
AND ONE OF THE LARGEST
COLLECTIONS IN THE COUNTRY.
AND SO THEIR IN BOXES.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE HOUSING IS
THAT.
I CONSIDER THAT A WALDRON AM
WITNESSES WORKED IN THE MUSEUM
SHE
A TO A PERSONAL EXPERIENCE YES
ALL OF THE HUMAN REMAINS A AT.
UC CAMPUSES ARE STORED IN ZIPLOC
BAGS AND BOXES ON SHELVES.
OKAY SO.
MIRANDA KINDA TESTIFIES A LOT TO
HOW.
SACRED.
OR THE ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THE
SACREDNESS OF THEM.
.
NO MY BROTHER IS A PHYSICIAN
AND.
YOU KNOW SOMETIMES.
AS FAMILIES WILL DONATE. A LOVED
ONE FOR RESEARCH.
AND.
HE'S HAD DURING HIS COURSE OF
WHEN HE WAS. JUST GOING TO
MEDICAL SCHOOL
SOMETIMES THE FAMILY WOULD
RECONSIDER THAT.
AND ASK FOR.
THE PERSON BACK SO THAT THEY
COULD DO A PROPER BURIAL ON YOU
KNOW.
AND THAT WAS ALWAYS COMPLIED
WITH.
BECAUSE OF THAT.
YOU KNOW. KIND OF A SACRED BOND
THERE BETWEEN LOVED ONES
AND THE FAMILIES AND I'M JUST
TRY I IT'S IT'S. DIFFICULT TO
GET MY HEAD AROUND HOW.
TWENTY YEARS THE TRIBES HAVE
BEEN WANTING TO HAVE THEIR LOVED
ONES RETURN AND.
YOU KNOW THERE'S LOTS OF RULES
OF LOTS OF BUREAUCRACY AND
EVERYTHING BUT.
I THINK YOU KNOW AS WAS STATED.
UNTIL WE RECOGNIZE THE
SACREDNESS.
OF.
YOU KNOW THE. AND THE RELIGIOUS.
IMPORTANCE.
OF BOTH THE ARTIFACTS THE
REMAINS AND EVERYTHING ELSE WILL
NEVER GONNA COME TO.
A THE REALIZATION THAT.
THE FAMILIES ARE ASKING FROM THE
BACK THAT'S THEIR PREROGATIVE
SO.
PLUS THE LAWS ON THEIR SIDE.
.
SO IT IS FRUSTRATING AND I HOPE.
THAT YOU WILL MEET TO GO LEARN
YOU KNOW WORK THIS OUT BUT I
THINK.
IT'S
TOO LATE TO WAIT ANYMORE THING
YOU KNOW WE NEED TO HAVE ACTION
ON IT.
SO.
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR THANK YOU.
GREAT.
COOPER TO COMMENT ON THAT
THERE'S.
FOR WELL I WANNA THANK YOU BEALL
SIR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL. OF
FOUR AND AND THANK YOU FOR.
DID PEOPLE TO COME AND TESTIFY.
AYE I CAN TOTALLY RELATE TO THAT
THIS ISSUE AND HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS.
YOU LOOK TO THE FAMILY MONEY.
A CHINESE AMERICAN.
CULTURAL BACKGROUND IN THE MOOD
REALLY.
I THINK VERY SIMILAR.
TO DID A NATIVE AMERICAN IN TERM
ALL FOR. YOU KNOW A BE ABLE TO
RETAIN THE S. SISTERS.
REMAINS AND.
AND HOW WE BAY AREA THAT AND
EVEN ON WHICH DIRECTION
THAT WOULD CHU BERRY THAT THIS
IS SO IMPORTANT SILICON BRADBURY
I MEAN I'M YOU MAY LAUGH HAD
THAT BUT IT THIS THIS THE.
THE CULTURE DATA.
WELL WE WE HOW FULL OF THOUSANDS
OF YEARS.
SO.
I AYE WILL ALSO WON'T THINK DO
YOU SEE FOR COMING UP HERE. OF
YOU LOOK A BIT LATE HONED YOU'VE
AND REGISTER FOR AN OPPOSITION
BUT OF. THOSE OF US THANK YOU
FOR COMING AND EAT IT JOIN US
TODAY AND I SEE IT SEEMS THAT
YOUR LOW WILL.
WILLING TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR.
AND TELL YOU MENTIONED THAT THE
FEMALE ALREADY BE SOME OF
PROCESS IN PLACE IN THE UC. BUT
I DON'T FEEL THAT IS BEING YOU
KNOW THIS BILL BEING IN THERE
REDUNDANT.
I'M HOPING WITH THIS BILL WOULD
BE ABLE TO EXPEDITE SOME OF THE
THAT THE.
.
THE GOAL IS TIGHT THAT DO YOU
SEE ONE OR TWO TO REACH
SO SO WAS DATA BE VERY HONORED
TO BE ALSO BE ADD THAT AS THE.
CO AUTHOR IN OB HARD TO THE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY.
MEMBER YOU WILL A CLOSE UP YES
MISTER CHAIRMAN I DID MY CAN
JUST SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR
FOR GIVING HER THIS BILL SUCH A
FULL AIRING THIS MORNING. OF
OBVIOUSLY IT'S OF GREAT
EMOTIONAL SIGNIFICANCE TO THE
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND I
APPRECIATE YOU GIVE IT THE TIME
THAT I THINK IT DESERVES OF THIS
MORNING TO YOUR COMMITTEE INTO
EVERY MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE.
ON YOUR STRONG OF VOICES AND
SUPPORT OUR PERSONALLY
MEANINGFUL AS A MENTION IN A WAR
BEING THE NLY.
INFILL TRIBAL MEMBER OUT OF A
HUNDRED TWENTY THE STATE
LEGISLATORS YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT
SOMETIMES YOU'RE IN ROOMS
WONDERING IF OTHER FOLKS WILL
UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU'RE COMING
FROM IF IT SIGNIFICANT TO YOU AS
WELL. CLEARLY FROM YOUR COMMENTS
YOU UNDERSTAND ITS IMPORTANCE OF
THIS AND YOU APPRECIATION ON IN
ANY COUNTRY IT CERTAINLY.
SO I'D LIKE EXPRESS THAT
APPRECIATION ON BEHALF OF SO
MANY OF. MY FELLOW NATIVE
AMERICANS AND MYRICK THANK YOU
FOR YOUR POWERFUL TESTIMONY I
WOULD JUST CLOSE BY RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR YOUR AYE VOTE HIGH
PROPITIATE THE UC BEING HERE
TODAY AND MISTER MURPHY LOOK
FORCING DOWN. A WITH THE ABOUT
YOUR YOUR FOLKS SUCH TALK IN
THIS AREA IN WHAT DETAIL A BUT
TO PUT IT SUCCINCTLY.
A JUST TO CORRECT THE RECORD
MAKE IT CLEAR MACRO WAS PASSED
BY CONGRESS A TWENTY EIGHT YEARS
AGO.
THE STATE TOOK ACTION IN
NINETEEN INSIGHT INTO THOUSAND
ONE SO THAT WAS SEVENTEEN YEARS
AGO.
WE ARE HERE TODAY NOT FOR LACK
OF PATIENTS AMENITIES
REPRESENTATION THAT'S GOOD FOR
THE DELAY THE DISPOSITION OF
THESE REMAINS AND REPATRIATION
OF THEM. ARM I THINK IS. IGNORES
THE ACTUAL REALITIES THAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE TO GET
APPRECIATION FOR ALL THE STRONG
COMMENTS THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU WOULD YOU HAVE A.
MOTION ON THE SECOND.
TO HAVE A MOTIONLESS HAVE.
ALRIGHT.
OKAY THANK YOU KNOW PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY SIX GLORIA D. PASSED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HIGHER
EDUCATION. KANSEN CHU ARE KANSEN
CHU AYE WALDRON. WALDRON AYE
ACOSTA AYE ACOSTA AYE DAVID
CHIU.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I MEDINA.
THIS AREA.
THIS AREA AND I.
THANK YOU YOUR BILLS OUT THERE
WILL BE LEE LIVED THE ROLE OPEN
FOR DAY MISTER MEMBERS.
THANK YOU.
MEMBER CHOL AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY
TWO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUT MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
HOW AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY TWO WELL
ESTABLISHED AND FUND A PROGRAM?
TO STUDY THE ROLE AND IMPACT OF
THE ELECTRONIC MEDIA IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF CHILDREN.
TO DATE THERE ARE ONLY
PRELIMINARY RESEARCH HAS BEEN
CONDUCTED TO.
RIGOROUSLY EXAMINE THE EXTENDED
USE.
ALL FOR ELECTRONIC MEDIA. AND
THE EFFECTS THAT THOUGHT CAN
HELP ON THE COGNITIVE LAW
PHYSICAL SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. OF CHILDREN.
AND ADOLESCENCE
EQUALLY INSUFFICIENT RESEARCH
HAS BEEN CONDUCTED TO RIGOROUSLY
EXAMINE THE USE OF ELECTRONIC
MEDIA TO SUPPORT CHILDREN'S
HEALTHY DEVELOPMENT. TO SHARE
WITH YOU SOME STATISTICS TODAY
NINETY EIGHT PERCENT OF CHILDREN
IN AMERICA UNDER THE AGE OF
EIGHT.
HAVE ACCESS TO A MOBILE DEVICE
AT HOME.
AND SEVENTY EIGHT PERCENT THEIR
OF TEENS A CHECK THEIR DIGITAL
DEVICES AT LEAST HOURLY. AND
FIFTY PERCENT OF TEENS UP REPORT
FEELING ADDICTED. TO THEIR
MOBILE DEVICES
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN BRAINS OF
YOUNG PEOPLE DIAGNOSED WITH
INTERNET ADDICTION SHOW
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS GRAY MATTER
DENSITY.
ASSOCIATED WITH PLANNING
DECISION MAKING AND ALSO IMPOSE
CONTROL.
THE RAPID RISE OF TECHNOLOGY AND
DIGITAL DEVICE THAT I USE AMONG
CHILDREN AND ADOLESCENTS HAS
CREATED. A YEAR PRESSING NEED TO
EXPAND RESEARCH INTO THE HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES OF TECHNOLOGY USE
AND POSSIBLE DIGITAL ADDICTIONS.
AND BOTH THE POTENTIALLY
POSITIVE AND NEGATIVE IMPACTS.
ARE INCREASED SO USAGE IS HAVING
ON THE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL AND ALSO
COGNITIVE. DEVELOPMENT OF
CHILDREN THIS BILL TWENTY SIX
SIXTY TWO WILL ESTABLISH A
PROGRAM. TO ENSURE EXPERTS OUT
STUDY THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE A
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY* OFF
WHERE I GO I HAVE ONE WITNESS
SO.
THAT NOW CAPITAL KEPT KAISER A
WITH THEIR COMMON SENSE KIDS
ACTION. THANK YOU.
THEY DON'T. GOOD MORNING DANIEL
CANDOR KAISER ON BEHALF OF
COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION I FIRST
WANT TO THINK THAT. THE
COMMITTEE IN THE CHAIR FOR YOUR
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. THE MISSION OF COMMON
SENSE IS TO PROVIDE PARENTS AND
EDUCATORS WITH THE TOOLS AND
RESOURCES TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS ABOUT THE MEDIA OTHER
CHILDREN USE.
THE ORGANIZATION HAS SUPPORTED
INNOVATIVE RESEARCH THROUGH
REPORTS SUCH AS COMMON SENSE
MEDIA AT THE CENSUS ON MEDIA USE
BY TEENS AND TWEENS.
THE TWENTY SIXTEEN TECHNOLOGY
ADDICTION SUMMARY.
VIRTUAL REALITY ONE A ONE WHAT
YOU NEED TO KNOW ABOUT KIDS IN
VIRTUAL REALITY AND MOST
RECENTLY THE TRUTH ABOUT TACK.
A ROADMAP FOR KIDS DIGITAL WELL
BEING.
BUT IT IS NOT ENOUGH FOR ONE OR
TWO GROUPS LIKE COMMON SENSE TO
TAKE THIS RESEARCH ON.
WE DO NOT HAVE THE COMPREHENSIVE
LONGITUDINAL DATA THAT WE SHOULD
HAVE ON BOTH THE UNSEEN POSITIVE
AND NEGATIVE EFFECTS OF THE
MEDIA OR CHILDREN CONSUME.
AT PRESENT WE ARE ESSENTIALLY
BETA TESTING ON OUR KIDS.
AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY TWO WOULD
ESTABLISH A PROGRAM TO SUPPORT
RESEARCH ON DIGITAL ADDICTION.
AND ITS POTENTIAL IMPACTS ON THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF OUR
KIDS.
AND IT WOULD SUPPORT RESEARCH
THAT CAN HELP PARENTS EDUCATORS
AND THE TECH INDUSTRY MAKE SMART
DECISIONS ON HOW TO MAXIMIZE TAX
POTENTIAL FOR GOOD.
AS WE'RE LOOKING TO OUR CHILDREN
WILL MATURE INTO ADULTS WE NEED
TO BE BETTER ABLE TO PLAN FOR
THEM AS THEY GO TO HIGH SCHOOL
COLLEGE AND BEYOND.
MORE THOROUGH RESEARCH ON HOW WE
ARE DOING NOW WILL GIVE US THE
INSIGHTS WE NEED TO RESOURCE
FAMILIES AND DETERMINE THE
SUPPORTS THEY WILL NEED
TOMORROW.
THANK YOU WE URGE YOUR IPHONE.
CHECK YOUR VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
SEEN DONE ANY OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONER DIES.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
YOU KNOW.
I JUST WANT TO ALSO THANK DR
AUTHORED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND MY GRAND
KIDS THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OWES
QUESTION IS THAT DISS OF
CONCENTRATING.
OWN THEIR A A CHILDREN WHO SAY
ANY RESEARCH DONE FOR THE ADULT
HARDEST IN SOME RESPECTS HER.
WELL THERE'S BEEN BEEN SOME
RESEARCH THAT UNDERPIN THAT.
LET ME GOOGLE VETERAN RIGHT BUT
WE WANT A CUT MORE COMPREHENSIVE
A LOT TO DO NO STEADY.
YOU KNOW AT LEAST ABOUT KIDS
THAT FOR NOW BUT BUT THAT I
THINK THAT THAT WOULD COME LATER
PROBABLY GOT IS A GOOD START
HISTORY NOTIFY REALLY OUR.
FUTURES SO OBVIOUS THAT ARE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT AND TERM.
YOU WILL CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR REGULAR MUCH MADAN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX SIXTY
TWO CHAU.
DO PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS KANSEN CHU AYE
KANSEN CHU AYE WALDRON. WALDRON
AYE ACOSTA AYE ACOSTA AYE DAVID
CHIU.
FRIEDMAN. TREATMENT AYE MEDINA.
MS AREA.
LIZ ARYAN I.
THANK YOU WHO BILLS AT ALL WOULD
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR THEM.
AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY SIX
BY MEMBERS NAZARIAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES I THINK YOU ALREADY
GOT A GREAT. DEMONSTRATION AND.
.
AND THE.
POINTS ABOUT WHY IT'S IMPORTANT
TO EXTEND THE FILM TAX CREDITS
SO. I'LL JUST THE JUMP N. AND
THE.
AND THEN.
I'M JOINED BY MELISSA PATAK AND
I BELIEVE MAYBE ONE OTHER
INDIVIDUAL. WHO I ARE GOING TO
BE MAKING SOME COMMENTS AS WELL?
A.
IT'S AN UNDERSTATEMENT TO SAY
THAT THE FILM INDUSTRY PLAYS A
VITAL ROLE IN THE ECONOMIC
STRENGTH OF CALIFORNIA BUT IT IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT.
AND THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
WHERE I'VE BEEN BORN WHERE I WAS
RAISED.
THEN ESPECIALLY THE GREATER LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AREA.
MY DISTRICT HAS HISTORICALLY
BEEN HOME TO THOUSANDS OF
INTERNATIONAL ALLIANCE OF
THEATRICAL STAGE EMPLOYEES
MEMBERS WHO HAVE WORKED IN LA'S
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY.
CALIFORNIA'S FILM TAX CREDIT WAS
REVAMPED IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
TO OFFER MORE INCENTIVE.
FOR SMALLER PRODUCTIONS TO STAY
IN CALIFORNIA FUNDING EXPANDED
TO THREE HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
AND THE AMOUNT OF TAX INCENTIVES
AVAILABLE TO. QUALIFIED
PRODUCTIONS TRIPLED DURING THE
FIRST TWO YEARS THERE WERE THREE
POINT SEVEN BILLION IN DIRECT IN
STATE SPENDING GENERATED. A TAX
CREDIT HAS ALSO PRODUCED A
SUSTAINED.
TWELVE PERCENT INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF HOURS WORKED IN THE
STATE BY BELOW THE LINE CREW
MEMBERS GENERATING AN ADDITIONAL
ONE POINT FOUR BILLION. IN THEIR
WAGES.
IT IS VITAL THAT CALIFORNIA WITH
ITS LONG HISTORY OF BEING THE
LEADER IN ENTERTAINMENT CONTINUE
COMPETITIVE POLICIES THAT OFFER
MEANINGFUL FINANCIAL INCENTIVES
TO RETAIN AND LOWER POST
PRODUCTION. JOBS AND SPENDING.
THERE ARE ELEMENTS OF THE
EXISTING PROGRAM THAT I HOPE TO
EXPAND ON AS MY MOVE UP BILL
MOVES THROUGH THE PROCESS.
FOR AREAS OF GREATEST CONCERN
ARE BOLSTERING THE INCENTIVES
FOR INDEPENDENT PRODUCTION
COMPANIES.
OF THE MUSIC PRODUCTION.
OF A IMPROVING DIVERSITY AND
ADDRESSING SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN
THE INDUSTRY.
AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY SIX ALLOWS
THE CALIFORNIA FILM COMMISSION
TO CONTINUE THE SUCCESSFUL
ECONOMIC STIMULUS AND.
INITIATIVES.
PROVIDED THROUGH THE FILM AND
TELEVISION TAX CREDIT PROGRAM BY
EXTENDING THE CURRENT PROGRAM
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
A I'M JOINED BY MELISSA PATAK.
OF OF THE MOTION PICTURE
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA.
QUIT DOT THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NEWS ARYAN.
MPA A.
WHICH IS A TRADE ASSOCIATION
FOR THE LEADING PRODUCERS AND
DISTRIBUTORS OF MOVIES AND TV
SHOWS ACROSS ALL PLATFORMS OUGHT
WE ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. ON AND WE THANK OUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NEWS AREA AND.
FOR HIS COMMITMENT TO.
EXTENDING THE PROGRAM FOR AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE YEARS WHAT
YOU'VE HEARD A LOT OF THE GREAT
CITY.
BOTH FROM ASSEMBLYMAN I NEWS
AREA AND OTHERS WHO TESTIFIED ON
THE OTHER BILL PREVIOUSLY BUT
IT'S BEEN.
THE CURRENT PROGRAM HAS BEEN A
HUGE SUCCESS THIRTEEN TV SERIES
HAVE RELOCATED TO CALIFORNIA
FROM OTHER STATES ARM.
OVER FIVE BILLION IN DIRECT
EXPENDITURES I IN THE STATE DOES
BOOST TO CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
AND.
.
I TO OVER TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
JOBS FOR THE BELOW THE LINE CREW
MEMBERS ARE AND IT'S A GREAT
PROGRAM IT MERITS.
SASS ARE AND CONTINUATION ON BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO WE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION SANK.
CARLA SALES WITH WARNER BROTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
YOU.
THE ONLY VENISON TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY FOX IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
GRAMLEY WITH CBS CORPORATION
HAPPY TO SUPPORT.
IF YOU.
ANOTHER GONZALEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
KATHY BUNDLES OF NBC UNIVERSAL
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TOM DAVIS HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
TIPSY COUNCILMEN SUPPORT WOULD
LOOK FOR WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR.
OUR MAN.
CONSOLIDATING ALL THE BILLS AND
MAKING THEM WORK.
AGAIN I THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING DANIEL CANDLE
BECAUSE ARE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAX FORM ASSOCIATION
WE ARE STILL ANALYZING THE BILL.
WE HAVE A LONG STANDING HISTORY
OF OPPOSING BILLS THAT SOUND
REDUCE THE GENERAL FUND REVENUES
BUT WE DO SEE A LOT OF BENEFITS
AND SPILL ME LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOUR OFFICE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CAN I JUST
ADD IN OUR MEMBER COMPANIES THE
WALT DISNEY COMPANY COULD BE HER
PERSON BUT THEY WANTED TO BE
ADDED IN IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
TOPIC WILL BE
SO COOLEY KNOW THAT ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE DANCE.
THE MEMBER ACOSTA.
YES I I'LL KEEP IT BRIEF.
.
I THINK THERE ARE A LOT MORE
PEOPLE HERE THAT WOULD HAVE
SAID.
ME TOO MANISA ISSUE IN MORE WAYS
THAN ONE.
BUT AS A COOPER THE BILL I
REALLY. WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD YOU
KNOW YOU REPRESENT.
MY AND MY HOUSE IN STUDIO CITY
WHERE I GREW UP IN CBS RADFORD
WERE.
MY DAD DID A LOT OF THINGS AND
MY ELEMENTARY SCHOOL THAT I
REPRESENT MY HELMET GRANADA
HILLS AND I REPRESENT A DISTRICT
THAT IS YOU KNOW HAVING BEEN UP
THERE ON THE SCENE IS ARYAN. OF
LOTS OF MOVIE RANCHES AND MOVIE
STUDIOS AND PRODUCTION ETCETERA
SO OF THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
PIECE OF THE PUZZLE AS WE PUT
ALL THIS TOGETHER AND MOVE
FORWARD WITH ALL THESE BILLS AND
AND RECONCILE THEM BUT I. WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR BRING IT
FORWARD INCLUDING THE IS A CO
AUTHOR. OF WE COULD WE DO NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR STATE
SAVES STAYS AS COMPETITIVE AS
POSSIBLE IN THIS INDUSTRY AMONG
OTHERS BUT CERTAINLY THIS IS A
GOOD START. AND I THINK HER
BRING IT FORWARD
AND OBVIOUSLY URGENT AYE VOTE.
ALRIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OF THIS
ADDITIONAL COMMENT.
ALRIGHT I WANNA THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A MEMBER IN THIS HEARING
FOR. BEING A VERY STRONG
ADVOCATE FOR YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
IN YOUR DISTRICT THIS BILL ONE
NOW ONLY BENEFIT YOUR
CONSTITUENTS
BUT ALSO BENEFIT. THE WHOLE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. M. I'M
HOPING THAT WE'LL BE ABLE TO
BRING SOME.
FILM INDUSTRY TO SILICON VALLEY
THE SAN JOSE WHAT I REPRESENT.
AND.
THIS IS NOT A EARLY AGE I WHICH
IS AGAINST AND.
WHO SUGGESTED THAT YOU WORK WITH
A ON CALDERON TO YOU WILL BE
ABLE TO?
COMES CONSOLIDATE INTO ONE BILL
AFTER. AND WHAT THEY DID THIS
ONE GET OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE SO
WOULD WISH THAT YOU ALL CLOSE.
A THE FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU A
TO TO THE MEMBER FROM.
AT VALENCIA AREA.
AYE I WAS HAPPY TO VISIT SOME
OF THE LOCATIONS THE RANCHES AND
I AM SORRY TO HEAR OF.
HOW MUCH DEVASTATION THE LAST
FIRES THAT BECAUSE IN THE AREA?
?
AND THE U.. I I'D LIKE FOR THIS
INSTITUTION AND THIS BODY A ONE
DAY.
FAR AWAY FROM NOW BUT TO COME
BACK AND SAY WE DON'T NEED THE
TAX CREDITS ANYMORE.
A THE JOBS AND THE TECHNOLOGY
ADVANCEMENT. A AND THE TALENT
POOL BUT THAT CONTINUES TO COME
TO CALIFORNIA HAS THE INDUSTRY
IN THE PLACE WHERE. OF A IT'S
BEEN RESTORED OR AT LEAST IT
CONTINUES TO GROW AND THRIVE. UP
BUT UNTIL THEN WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE PUTTING MEASURES
IN PLACE. THAT ARE GONNA PROTECT
THIS INDUSTRY A AND THE NUMBER
COUNTLESS NUMBER OF LIVES THAT
DEPEND ON ON THE THE GROWTH OF
THIS INDUSTRY. SO WITH THAT I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE NOT
ONLY MY COLLEAGUE IN THE
ASSEMBLY BUT THE TWO SENATORS
ALSO THAT HAVE. BILLS OUT IN
THIS AREA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU GOOD LUCK.
BUT DON'T SECRETARY TREES CALL
THE ROLL. ASSEMBLY FELL TWENTY
NINE THIRTY SIX NAZARIAN DEEP
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
REVENUE TAXATION.
KANSEN CHU OUR KANSEN CHU AYE
WALDRON AYE WALDRON AYE ACOSTA
AYE ACOSTA AYE DAVID CHIU.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I MEDINA.
MS ARYAN.
I KNOW VERY AND I.
THANK YOU YOU VOTED OUT YOU
BILL'S STYLE WILL.
THE FIGURE PULLED ROAD OPEN FOR
FIVE MINUTES.
SO YOU ASK THE SERGEANT TO WHO
CAN GUESS ALMOST REMEMBER BACK.
THANK YOU.
WELL
ALRIGHT. TO THE ARTS
ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS TOURISM AND
MEDIA TECHNOLOGY COMMITTEE
MEETING NOW A JORDAN.
ALRIGHT LIVING THERE.
YEAH